hi everyone if you could take a seat
that'd be awesome
I'm Cadman yella I'm one of the partners
at Y Combinator I wanted to thank the
Riveter for hosting us here today I love
this space I don't like I wish I lived
in Seattle so I could work here every
day so I'm cat I'm one of the partners
at Y Combinator and for those of you who
might not be very familiar with YC we
fund startups and we fund we funded
about 1500 companies since 2005 and
actually one of my partner's Kirstie
Nathu who you'll meet a little bit later
today has personally seen a thousand
startups over a thousand startups go
through the program yeah she's a grad
ball and so we have run female founders
conference for five years now because
we've personally seen how important it
is to have a community of people around
you if you want your starter to be
successful building a startup so how
many of you are building startups right
now
awesome that's incredible so as you know
building startups is hard and oftentimes
very lonely work and so if you have and
build a community of smart hard-working
people around you who around you who can
push you who can ask you the hard
questions who can help you through
challenges your chances of success are
just going to be exponentially more
likely and so the female founders
conference community as I said has been
you know around for about five years now
and it's about 6,000 women strong and
we've seen some women in our community
do incredible things for example Reshma
Shetty she was one of our speakers two
years ago it was just announced that her
company is now valued at over a billion
dollars didn't go by works right we have
a woman who was in the audience three
years ago at you know three female
founders conferences ago she was in the
audience and she wrote in her notebook
in two years I want to be on stage she
was on stage as a speaker last year and
she's going to be on stage today
it's ovni Patel Thompson who's building
poppy here in Seattle and in this batch
of YC winter 2018 we actually just
funded two women who met two years ago
at a female founders conference they
started talking two years ago
they stayed in touch they started
building side projects together and now
they're working on their company
full-time and are in the batch so I hope
you know I hope that is the case for all
of you today that you start meeting each
other and helping support each other as
your companies and projects grow so I
you know we at YC I want to see more
women starting companies and for those
of you who have already started I want
to see you building billion-dollar
companies and so I so you know I really
believe that building a platform where
women can learn from each other and help
each other as they grow will help us get
there faster so today you're gonna hear
from women who are at various stages of
building their companies so you'll hear
from folks who are at seed stage folks
who raised you know in the 20 plus
million dollar category you'll hear from
a bunch of investors and I hope also
that you meet women here's who you're
sitting next to today and you'll keep in
touch and and support each other in the
community as you're startups take off
and grow so the first speaker you're
gonna hear today is Omni Patel Thompson
the founder of poppy poppy is a site
that connects parents with great
caregivers for their children so AVI and
her co-founder went through Y Combinator
in winter 2016 and she's also an
incredible advocate of this Seattle
startup community and Omni is really one
of the main reasons we are here today so
so welcome Avni hi everyone it's just so
amazing to see you all here today it is
amazing for me to have the FFC up here
for those of you that know me and my
story of the female founder conference
is an important part of my story and
I've just always loved the energy when
you get all of these incredible women
together with ideas and big bold visions
it's just lots of impressive things can
happen so I'm of nee I'm the co-founder
and CEO of poppy our mission is to build
the modern village that every family
deserves and we do this by connecting
these talented vetted caregivers to
families when they need childcare and on
the caregivers side we find amazing
folks that have a passion for and it's
held for childcare and we connect them
to families so that they can make some
extra income on a flexible schedule and
it's beyond just your average kind of
sitters and nannies these are teachers
and stay-at-home moms
they can be dance instructors and camp
counselors really just incredible people
that have a passion and experience in
childcare and then we connect them to
families as their safety net this is
pretty exciting to me because I'm a
parent my husband and I have two little
girls saya is almost six and Aria is
three and we have been there we have
been there where both of us are working
we don't have family in town and
inevitably something goes wrong your
nanny is sick a meeting runs long and
when you're stuck without your safety
net it can be a major issue and so I
started papi not because I've had this
lifelong dream of starting a childcare
company I started papi because I had a
problem and it was a problem that I was
convinced that technology could help me
solve but it didn't matter that I have
never worked at a software company let
alone build one it didn't matter that
I'm not a developer and had no way to
build an app and it really didn't matter
that at the same time I embarked on this
journey was the exact same time I
decided to start having kids all that
mattered was that I felt like parenthood
was broken in a little bit of a way you
know Parenthood is hard enough and when
you are going through all of these
things I couldn't imagine a future for
future parents that felt this broken and
so for me it was if somebody was going
to be building a future that solved this
it might as well be me and so that
really was the genesis for papi where I
thought I could use technology to be
able to solve a really important problem
that in my life but in other people's
lives and the thing is I thought that if
we could solve this
so today we're about ten people we are
thriving and we're growing really
quickly and if I look back on the
journey of the last three years from the
first very idea of poppy all the way
through to where we are right now I
think the thing that I reflect on is if
I let all those things that sort of
stood in my way all the reasons that why
I shouldn't be a founder kind of stopped
me from doing it
poppy wouldn't exist and that's sort of
a shame it's more than a shame it's a
big important idea that has to have its
chance and so I guess what I worry about
is that how many other people are
focused on all the ways and all the
reasons and all the obstacles that kind
of stand in your way instead of figuring
out a path to how we can figure out to
build these amazing companies so that's
what I want to talk to you today it's
something that I'm super passionate
about if I think about this last three
years I think there's sort of two big
phases this sort of phase one that I
like to call kind of get going or live
to fight another day and there's the
second phase which is get growing or you
know just proving that this concept
really can scale and so my hope is that
if we can talk about this openly the
stages even to get to where I am today
and there's so much more that we have
left to do so much exciting stuff for us
to do in the future but if I could get
even a hundred a thousand more companies
more founders to the stage that I am
right now
think about all the incredibles problems
we'll be solving think about all the
incredible founders we'll have and so
that's what I want to get to so that if
we can talk about this openly maybe we
make this journey a little less
mysterious a little less lonely and
definitely a lot more accessible so
that's what I hope to do today and share
just a couple of the things that I've
found not necessarily so intuitive and
hopefully in doing so we can start a
dialogue and start getting more people
started and going so to start before I
get to the idea of poppy a quick little
background on what brought me there my
background has nothing to do with tech
I actually have a pretty traditional
corporate career I started my career at
a company called Procter and Gamble they
make things like pampers and tide and
crest and when I started there I had the
opportunity to be trained in their
vision of brand management and what that
means is they taught me how to see
consumer problems not as consumers say
them and speak them to us but as they
actually experience them and that's a
really important distinction because
when you're trying to solve consumer
problems often people can't articulate
the real pain the real friction that's
going on in their lives and so I started
there I went on and I did my MBA did
consulting for a little while I
continued in sort of my big company path
all very traditional all the way through
to my husband and I moving to Seattle
and I was at Starbucks and still a
really engaging really great career but
I think at that point for me my
entrepreneurial sort of bug had been I
was bit by the entrepreneurial bug and
at that point I said you know what I
want to go start something it was about
2012 lots of people are starting lots of
interesting things and for me
I thought I come from a world of retail
e-commerce and I have a great passion
for you know the world and culture and
travel and now that I had my first
daughter
I was really also passionate about
passing that culture on to my kids and
so a friend and I started a company
called papaya and post it was a
subscription ecommerce company aimed at
raising culturally curious kids
basically think about a different month
a different culture done in a really
thoughtful I thought and engaging kind
of way languages and food and things
like that and you know I did it in all
the way that did my research I did the
numbers did the business plan I did all
the things they were supposed to do
built the product that you know we would
have loved to have for our families and
then we launched it spent a lot of money
and a lot of timing relatively a lot of
time and as it turns out it was a
beautiful product people did think it
was great just know enough to buy it
regular basis and so that's a hard
lesson for those of you that have
e-commerce companies you always have to
make sure that customer acquisition cost
for us that was just too high we had
such a niche market of folks that had
the interest and the drive for a second
culture to share that with their kids
and then the LTV or the long term value
also wasn't there and that what that
means it's just how many of those boxes
would they buy over their lifetime so we
learned the hard way that that just
wasn't in sync the customer acquisition
cost and the LTV and ultimately we came
to the decision to shut that down and
that was a hard process but I think the
right process because you have to be
true to what your intent is and my
intent has always been to build a
scalable company that disrupts a
category and again even for in my
background in my previous career it's
never been the what I've worked on
Footwear in apparel and foot and food
and Bev in healthcare my connection to
that has always been working on really
important consumer problems and in the
same way here for me I really wanted to
build a massive company that just took a
massive swing at something and so it was
really hard because I thought I did
everything I was supposed to I used up I
had talked to my husband and I had
talked and basically said we could go a
year without you taking a salary and I'd
used pretty much all of that year up and
I'd used a pretty much all of the money
that I'd set aside for startups the
savings that I'd put into this and so
that was sort of a tough position to be
in
but as I started to talk to parents
about why wasn't this the thing that you
need it or it didn't solve a problem
urgent enough then what are the problems
in your life and I think it's it's funny
how themes just kind of come up over and
over and the thing that kept on coming
up was the topic of child care and not
really even oh I can't find a nanny or
my sitter just cancelled on me what was
underneath was everyone was saying I
miss my village
I missed that safety net of knowing I
could text someone that I trust and know
that they'll be there when I need them
to be you know for so many of us we move
around for our careers for our education
communities aren't necessarily what they
used to be you know asking a neighbor to
take care of care for your child is a
hard thing and so we don't have those
villages but that function still is
necessary for us as parents and so as I
started to talk to more and more people
I could see the solution the way that I
talk about this is that I have a
chemistry undergrad and I think about it
in an equation if village is a function
of someone that you trust is a match for
is a fit for your family and is
available when you need them to be then
that can also be approximated with a
vetting mechanism a matching algorithm
and some sort of scheduler and so for me
I could already see how I could I had a
hypothesis on how I might approximate
village using technology at each of
these key kind of pieces which brings me
so to the point and the idea of papi and
so now if we think about that first
stage what is so important of get going
I had a couple of problems first of all
I could see how I wanted the solution to
happen but it was a tech and an app
solution and I am NOT a developer my
traditional background didn't have me
working with engineers so I didn't have
a co-founder ready and lined up and more
than that I had run out of basically
time and money that I had set aside
forget about myself but my agreement
with my family and my husband to go and
do this and so I guess the point is
there is that I was if it was already
constrained it was I was under lots of
more constraint and so if I think about
the first stage which is about getting
going the whole point here is about
validating if your idea matters and so
if I had this much all of these
different constraints how could I still
buy myself the time to validate the idea
and figure out whether I even needed to
worry about co-founders and tech and all
that kind of stuff and so my mantra was
pretty much just solved the thing in
front of me if I could solve the biggest
problem in front of me I'd figure out
the next one next and so in that
instance it was I needed to buy time to
do more things
so I basically basically to give myself
some kind of structure I gave myself the
construct of four weeks
can I buy myself four weeks to be able
to show whether people want what I'm
making
and so I approximated the whole flow
that I'm talking about using just
off-the-shelf things and that is one of
the most exciting things of living in
the tech world today is that there are
so many off-the-shelf solutions that for
very few things and especially for
consumer problems you can just literally
build something off the shelf and so I
did that for me what what am I trying to
do I'm trying to connect vetted trusted
people with families when they have gaps
in care well so I found three u-dub
students vetted them in any way that
like is the top-of-the-line background
checks references in-person interviews
then I found 15 families in Madison Park
where I was living and I said hey if you
need a caregiver this week and you have
a gap and care just text this phone
number because SMS is a great
communicator and that day we got our
first booking and that week who we got
our first four so great I've got a
baseline I've got four bookings and I
just need to grow it next week by 10%
which is five it doesn't sound like a
lot but it's it does two things one it's
discipline if you hold yourself to 10%
growth every single week I assure you
that five grows pretty quickly and then
the other thing is that having having a
goal and then hitting it and for me I
because this actually struck a nerve of
something that people really needed and
wanted we ended up going faster than the
10% in those early days so instead of
five we actually ended up at six and
then so on so forth and that is an
incredible confidence booster especially
coming off of a failure when you really
don't have any data points to suggest
that you should go give it another shot
and so the four week test for me did a
couple of things it reduced the risk for
me who's I'm in a pretty risk-averse
person and it made it I could I could
devote for weeks and I took it I gave it
the $200 that I had left in my business
bank account and I said I can spend
another
$200 and by doing that that sort of time
bound and risk bound to all of that and
then as we got going I could quickly see
how consumer both both sides just wanted
and loved what we were doing and so
parents would tell other parents sign
ups would just start coming in and I
can't tell you how different that is
versus the first startup when you're
just trying to tell everyone to do
something and no one does it and this
one you don't even telling anyone and
they're just signing up and the things
are coming through and it feels
incredibly different and so that was
really important in the early days is
that when you're talking about
validating your idea your your purpose
is learning it's not about optimizing
for revenue or all of those things in
these early days you just have to pick
something and get going so for me that
meant you know just starting with some
kind of pricing mechanism that we think
you know made sense and just get into
market and so for me at the end of the
four weeks it literally was something I
couldn't shut down it had just gained a
life of its own which is amazing and
felt really great but also when it's
just you doing all those things in a
pretty janky way you need to just keep
it going and so what those four weeks
bought me was not only time to keep on
going but I quickly realized what my
next problem I had to solve and that was
I had to find a technical co-founder and
that made that pretty apparent and so I
continued to keep everything going and
growing to be able to buy that
additional time but I quickly turned my
attention to finding a technical
co-founder and I think I'll pause on
this thing because I think there's a lot
of you know women out there that don't
come from technical backgrounds maybe
don't have engineers and I think there's
a lot of opera options open to us you
can work with a dev shop somewhere you
can work with a contract engineer you
could even have a VP of engineering that
reports to you I have I'm pretty biased
but I have a strong feeling that if your
intention is to build a tech company you
have to have a tech partner along your
sell alongside you and that means
co-founder level that means someone
who's at the table at constantly pushing
each other on ideas I'm
technical so by definition I cannot see
the disruptive ways that technology can
solve this problem and so for me even
though I had all of these folks that
were saying that you know either dev
shops or other types of engineers I was
pretty clear that I wasn't going to
pursue those paths even though it would
have been a short-term relief that would
have sort of cut the vision and the
ambition of this idea off at the knees
and so and I'm not saying that this is
easy this is one of the hardest things I
almost died and I've said this before
but we almost died through growing too
big too quickly without somebody else to
build the platform and so it took
probably about three or four months and
just constantly talking to as many
people as I could to find the right
person because again for those of you
that have a co-founder that's awesome
because you know how hard it is to find
these people that can be in the trenches
and be that lifeline for you there's of
course division of labor but beyond that
it's almost the emotional support
there's so many ups and downs on the
thing and so you can be the highest high
on one day and at noon the lowest low
and so you need sort of that partnership
to even that out and so it took a couple
of months talked to so many what feels
like hundreds of different candidates
but finally I had the chance to connect
with my now co-founder and CTO Richard
and we ended up clicking just right off
the bat we started talking about ideas
really love that but ultimately it came
down to can we work together and so we
just set it up again as a six-week test
of like can we work together can you
build something from a platform
perspective and can we work together and
let's just see by doing so again not a
lot of talking we just got to the first
point of saying are you in um are you in
and just got going that was really
important because by doing that we both
were able to see and assess whether we
were good partners whether we were both
engaged in this mission and this is
something that we could do together I
later learned and because this is also
one of those most common questions that
I'll get how did you find a technical
co-founder as it turns out by me
focusing on growth
that also helped me solve this problem
because if you can imagine four talented
engineers think about how many people
are coming to them and saying I've got
an idea
you need to build it that's not awesome
and so what he was excited about was
that I had already started and got
gotten going and so he wanted to come on
and you know get onto that rocket ship
and get get it going even faster and
further so that solved my co-founder
problem the next thing was we needed
money and so growth also helps you with
that because you can dismiss me but you
can't dismiss my growth and so that
helped when I applied to YC in the
interview I was able to show the actual
growth that people actually wanted what
I was making it also ultimately helped
us get our incredible investors I'm not
saying that in raising money is ever
easy but certainly this time around
because I could focus on what we were
building the actual growth that was
happening and this wasn't me talking in
ideas it was really important and we
were able to raise that money so this
stage one is really about validate your
idea get to a hundred paying users that
love what you're making and you'll be
able to figure out and just focus on
growth you'll be able to figure out the
rest
so stage two is about get growing and
get to a place where you get to product
market fit and you're ready to scale a
lot of this is about growing up and into
a company and I found that my role as a
founder sort of had to shift from
putting out fires and just surviving to
evening out into the marathon that is a
startup and so this for us started after
we returned from YC we raised our seed
round of a little bit over two million
dollars and now we had the chance and
the space and the time to actually build
poppy into what it can be so the first
thing here is about hiring about a team
and I thought after 10 years of having
experience you know with big companies
and hiring I thought I knew how to do
this and it took me many months and many
tries to realize I didn't things like
references things like prior experience
or pedigree of what school you went to
don't matter that
what does matter is commitment and
resourcefulness passion for the mission
and one really great example I like to
share is about our head of ops Rebecca
at the time that she emailed me just out
of the blue she was a poppy parent using
poppy and she was just intrigued at you
know how what we were doing and what we
were up to and so she just emailed me
out of the blue and said we'd love to
grab coffee and I was intrigued as well
and loved to talk to interesting people
who are using our product so I said why
not and as I talked to her and as we
started to you know just chat about all
the challenges I realized here's someone
who maybe hasn't done operations or
worked at a start-up but it's so engaged
on the mission knows it then what could
be better than having empathy for the
product firsthand and wanting that kind
of passion for doing it and so I think
in that I could repeat for so many roles
at our company so hiring becomes less
about pedigree or past experiences or
things like that but the people that can
prove to you that they have a passion
for your mission and your problem and
can get in and get going the next thing
is that you need to build a company and
it needs to even out you need to do
things that maybe you had a hypothesis
on different business model things but
now you need to actually have a
sustainable business model and so for us
for example at the beginning I had
started with a pricing thing where we
had a membership parents paid us
membership and then they just paid the
caregivers that worked but it didn't
work so well for us we didn't make
nearly enough money for us to be a
sustainable enterprise and so we had to
take the it's--it's pricing is always a
hard thing but we had to make the
decision that if we were going to
survive we would have to take some cut
of that transaction or the hourly rate
and so we did we talked to tons of
caregivers and Families we did all the
research and we you know built it into
the systems and we put it out papi did a
lot of growing up that week not because
it wasn't the right thing to do it was
and it is but because I think I'd
underestimated how much early users feel
ownership of your product and so we had
never talked about margin issues I had
never talked about some of the
challenges of being in this category so
people felt blindsided
and I think the lesson that I took away
that day was those early users are a
part of your company and you need to
bring them in and you need to respect
them with transparency there's lots of
these types of examples but in this
phase you are going to need to do hard
how to make hard decisions to make your
business sustainable in the interest of
having it survive just be mindful of the
facts that make it as transparent and
bring your bring your users along
through all of those changes
the last thing I'll just touch on is to
sort of it seems like minor things but
one is things like investor updates and
the other is mentors there's a reason I
didn't talk about advisors and mentors
in the first phase it can be a
distraction at that phase you know what
you need to do to validate your idea
there's no one else that can tell you
how to do that you just need to get
there in the trenches and do it but the
second stage as you as you settle into
the marathon you the founder need to
surround yourself with one to a couple
of people that you trust to be the
mirror to you because your job is to
always advocate for the mission and
everything like that but you need
someone to hold yourself accountable and
so having a couple of those folks that
don't necessarily agree with you on your
points of view but can push you on those
important things those are that's a
those are really important people to
have and then my quick point on investor
updates it feels like a little one but I
am always surprised at how few people do
it because it feels scary and it feels
like you know maybe I'm messing up and I
don't want everyone to know about it
it's important discipline to start as
early as possible and to be fair I
didn't do it until after YC but it's
important because again it holds you
accountable and it's the least that you
can do for your investors for the
privilege of their money so that's
basically what I feel like were the two
most important parts for stage one and
kind of phase two for my company to get
to where it is today and I guess I feel
like if we can get so many more
companies and all of you to even that
stage I think that would be an
incredible kind of thing to get to the
last thing I'll just kind of touch on is
a couple of points of how to scale
yourself as a founder
I think so many people say being a
founder is hard it is it is hard for all
the reasons that you might expect and so
many that you don't the most important
reasons I think is because you need to
be really sure you want to be a founder
and what I mean by that is it isn't just
the sprint at the very beginning or
maybe a couple years in you have to be
sure you want to do this for the next
five ten years of your life maybe it
won't take that long but you know often
it does and so do you want to devote
your life to that great answer that
question next talk to your family your
spouse anyone else make it very clear
about your intention because it's
important to create the space to be that
founder because it's going to be brutal
and you need to be able to show it be
sure that you can make that commitment
it's also okay if that answer isn't
maybe yes there's a lot of us startups
that could use amazing smart people to
work at our startups for a couple of
years until you figure out whether
that's the thing for you it also gives
you really amazing experience to then
start your startup at an advantage the
last point I'll make is you need to take
care of yourself I think for myself
because I'm a parent because I'm a
founder it is too easy to say I don't
have time for that and I have learned
through doing and making this mistake
that that is another way to kill your
company and what I mean by that is you
need to give yourself the time to take
breaks for me it's yoga and that's sort
of like a three-in-one for me because it
gives me a chance to sort of work out
give my mind a break and just you know
reassess and regen riajuu Vinay because
if you as a founder aren't at your peak
you can't provide everyone else what
they need and I think the the parallel
to Parenthood is really great there I'm
so many of us parents you know just give
and give and give and then you realize
you're just completely burnt out it's
the same thing with startups you don't
don't get yourself to that point where
you have nothing left to give and you're
burnt out and so if you make that as a
part of your practice and you create
that space I think that's just a really
important thing so YC applications are
due on March 24th
that is fifty days seven weeks if you
haven't started that gives you two weeks
to plan something four weeks to do it
and one week to write the application if
you have started seven weeks to go grow
and that application will just write
itself in a day my point is is that we
need more people standing on this stage
at this phase to even have a shot at all
these big bold problems that we all have
so let's get into that arena
let's build those big bold companies and
most of all let's stop focusing on all
those hurdles that lie in our way and
figure out how to just get started
Thank You Abney next you're going to
meet Cade Rijn Cowen sage who I have the
pleasure of working with @yc she's a
software engineer at Y Combinator and
she's the founder of leap an online
community that I'll let her tell you
more about right now hi I'm Kay dren I
as you heard I'm a software engineer at
YC and the creator of leap it's a
private online network for women in tech
to talk about whatever we want and I'm
so excited to be here and to tell you
about it so I first started working on
leap because I didn't feel like I had a
place online where I could talk openly
I felt like conversations online often
escalate quickly to shouting matches and
people opt-out especially women and I
wondered what would happen if I created
a community where the core culture was
set by women and the product and
software decisions were also made by
women I couldn't think of a community
like that but I wanted to be I wanted to
be part of one so the idea for leap
actually first started at the first
female founders conference I'd flown in
from New York where I lived at the time
and I was sitting in the audience and
was struck by the number of smart driven
women all in one room and it was strange
because in my day to day life I had a
handful of female friends who worked in
tech but it felt like there were very
few of us but when I looked around the
room at the conference I realized how
many of us there actually were how many
strong technical experts with so many
great ideas so many connections and so
much power so when I started working at
YC Leap started as a place where me and
my colleagues could just kind of talk
and get to know you know more about our
ideas and what we were thinking about
and once I validated that we actually
wanted to use the product I fixed some
bugs
we started sharing leap with the the
network of female founders at YC our
friends and former colleagues and
organizations that support women of
color and organizations that support
women in engineering so another part
about leap is that we use our real
identity it's on there and that is you
know the idea behind that is that in my
life the relationships that have been
the strongest are the ones that are
based on these social and and
professional interactions and so my
hypothesis was that if we created a
network that was a hybrid social and
professional community that it would
foster you know civil discourse and
authentic conversations and so that was
you know the the core of leap and the
idea is that you know those kind of
relationships can help propel us in the
industry on leap you can go talk about
you know your favorite book with another
member and then a few days later or
whatever it is that that other women can
help you find your next job or your next
investment I've already heard stories
from members about finding co-founders
and and finding new jobs so that's super
exciting to me so we are at this point
about 2,000 members strong we are
software engineers founders VC's
designers writers we work in sales and
operations the list goes on so we talk
about all sorts of things too you know
one day it's conversations about career
development and the next we're talking
about you know tactical issues we're
having with our companies we talk about
everything from relationships with our
partners to raising kids our favorite
books and our favorite podcasts
you know all sorts of stuff so if you
think that leap sounds interesting you
can go to leap dot Y Combinator com so
that's leap you may see it over there in
blue in a few minutes it's le AP leap
dot Y Combinator calm and we'd love to
have you join so looking forward to
getting to know you on leap
[Applause]
okay hi everyone next part of the the
session is going to be a fundraising
panel where we have three ladies from
the Seattle scene who is going to impart
some advice on how they've they've
approached fundraising and and some of
the lessons that they've learned my name
is Kirsty Nathu I'm one of the partners
at Y Combinator I'm the CFO there so I
look after all of the finance for both
YC internally and also helping founders
with raising money looking at cap tables
understanding dilution so seen seen a
lot and seen seen a lot of if things
happen during fund raising just to give
you a couple of stats in 2017 only 2% of
VC funding went to all female founding
teams and only 12% went to mix gender
teams so there's a lot of work to be
done there and we hope that the you
ladies in the audience can help to
change that trend and really get those
numbers up in the future so I'm going to
pass over to the ladies now what they'll
do a much better job of introducing
themselves so each of you if you want to
just explain a little bit about your
company who you are and how much you've
raised so far hi thanks Kirsten here so
I'm Beth Kolko and I am the founder
co-founder of shift labs which is a
medical device company here in Seattle
and I started the company after being a
professor for many years including at
u-dub and we have raised a total of uh
well 1.7 million of dilutive and then a
$300,000 grant so just about two million
dollars which for a med tech company is
not a lot and we have a product that's
on the market and approved in the US as
well as Europe and a few other places so
that's what I do is what I have been
doing and fundraising is
well I will just say this when I told my
partner what I was doing he said you
know don't take this the wrong way honey
but you know you've done a lot of things
really well but they do know that
fundraising has been the hardest thing
for you right I was like yeah it has
been so maybe that's why I'm here
my name is Amy Nelson and I'm the
founder and CEO of the Riveter and we're
really excited to host the conference
today and to have all of you here um we
launched our this base our first base in
May the Riveter is female forward
workspaces and community for business
and impact we launched our second space
in September and we have raised a
proceed last spring of seven hundred and
twenty thousand and then we're about
halfway through a seed round right now
so in an interesting position to be on
this panel kind of in the middle of
everything but a fundraising is hard but
it's necessary and it's important to
learn how to do it and how to do it well
and so I'm happy that we can all be up
here to tell our stories and that small
piece of that hi everybody I just want
to say that I've never seen this space
look more beautiful than today and I've
seen it before but it looks amazing you
are all incredibly beautiful how many
people here are in the process of
starting a company or have started a
company awesome congrats and we are here
for you and each other my name is
Kristen Hamilton I am the CEO and
co-founder of karu we do predictive
hiring so we're helping employers choose
the right talent using machine learning
and AI and ultimately leveling the
playing field to provide access to
opportunity for people based on things
like what they can do instead of where
they went to school
I've we've raised 15,000
$15,000 sum we've raised we've raised 15
million dollars in three rounds and this
company the there's a story in each
round but I'm guessing we're gonna get
to that a once dad I'd like to share
that someone shared with me that was
daunting but interesting they said
you're more likely to get struck by
lightning than to raise for them to get
a term sheet from a Silicon Valley
venture investor said he told me that
when I was in the process of fund
raising so I just want to be here to say
that it's all possible despite the odds
and getting more and more possible so
this is gonna be good we have a lot of
different perspectives here so first of
all let's talk a little bit about where
where the money came from did you raise
money from people here in Seattle or did
you have to go further afield and if you
did go further afield did you see any
real differences in the the different
geographic locations that made you have
to change your approach so we raised we
went through we went through YC in
winter 15 and before that we had done a
small incubator here in Seattle for a
kind of social conscious companies
called fledge we did a kind of small we
raised a little bit of money mostly
friends and family kind of stuff before
we got into YC most of her money who was
raised as a result of Y C's demo day and
I gotta be completely honest about that
so a medtech is pretty traditional in
terms of investment least med devices
and our team didn't come from that
background that was sort of part of our
super power in terms of thinking about
the product but it made fundraising
really challenging so what worked for us
was to tap into people's optimism and
desire to change the world and so they
advised the investors who really came
into that first seed round after demo
day were people who believed in the
vision and also were willing to think
not just about the US but globally and
so most of those investors came for
California came from Silicon Valley some
came from other parts of the world as
well some institutional but a lot of
angels and so they just they it it
seemed like they had more appetite for
risk and they'd they were surrounded by
more risky things and so they were
willing to look at us and say hey why
not so that was a big difference future
fundraising activities similar to where
you're at is um you know now we're at a
different position and now we actually
are reaching out into that medtech
community which again asks is not is
interested in risk and has different
kinds of metrics and so it's about
adapting to that so we definitely see
differences geographically as well as
based on what people's backgrounds are
um I talked about in the angel round
that we raised and then how I've I have
approached raising the seed round an
angel round that we raised
we raised on a safe so and it's an
important kind of precursor to going out
to raise is deciding the vehicle on
which you will raise which is something
I had to learn about I was a lawyer for
ten years so it was you know brand-new
to all of this when I started this a
year ago so we decided on the vehicle we
would raise on and then I kind of
stumbled into my first angel investors
by attending events so I went to startup
week and I raised my hand I think you
were on the panel I was that was at the
mompreneur panel yes and I raised my
hand and asked a question and prefaced
it by talking about my business because
I would say that is the one thing you
have to talk about what you're doing to
everyone because you never know who
you're talking to
so you know I raised my hand and asked a
question about the business and
afterward a woman came up to me and
asked me some questions about it I ended
up pitching her and she became my first
investor my second investor I was in my
daughter's co-op preschool class talking
to another mother who I barely knew
about what I was doing and she said you
should talk to my husband he's a serial
entrepreneur he became my second
investor and then introduced me to my
third and fourth investors and so for me
that was really a lesson and you you
don't know you know who who does angel
investing and who you know who you're
talking to who might be interested in
your business on the flip side I then
went ahead after
kind of instances I went ahead and made
a list of people in my network or people
I wanted to invest and then for the
people I wanted to invest I found
connections to them
I was super methodical about it you know
spreadsheet going on LinkedIn I want to
connect to person X who can introduce me
asking that people to introduce me and
seeking out those really warm
connections which i think is massively
helpful in fundraising which makes sense
because you know it's easier to say yes
to taking the time to listen to someone
or listen to an idea if you have an
introduction from a trusted person and
then the final piece I guess about the
angel investing piece that I learned a
lot in the precede round is that that
early in a company and I was raising
money when the Riveter was just an idea
that I had you know I had a deck and an
idea and myself and angel investors and
early early investors are largely
investing in the founder and what they
think if they think you can pull it off
and so you have to be really confident
that you can and project that and
present that every way that you can with
the VCS and approaching the seed round I
at the beginning I don't think I was
incredibly organized about how I would
go out and do it and then I realized
what I needed to do was put together a
full deck which I didn't want to do it
because it's like a high school project
like oh I have to sit down and write all
the slides and but it's really really
important because it's what people will
look at when they're you know being
introduced to your business and thinking
about it so made a deck and then I sat
down and I made a long list of VCS that
I wanted to talk to and then once again
I figured out a way to get warm
introductions which it took a lot of
time I completely underestimated how
much of my time as the CEO would go to
fundraising in the early days but that's
that's kind of and then I've gone
geographically all over the country both
times so just in terms of where our
investors come from they come from
Seattle they come from San Francisco Los
Angeles New York Boston everywhere which
is everywhere the riveter will be so
yeah when we were on the mompreneur
panel I asked when the dad preneur panel
was going to be so I've raised money in
seven different rounds of venture and
that one one failed so seven plus one
failed that plus upon IPO so scattered
geographically everywhere I would say
and my learning has been to generalize
and stereotype Silicon Valley investors
are the most risk tolerant and do the
least due diligence in some they have
they have had so many more reps you know
it's just about learning right then most
of them many of them have then other
cities so that city has just that
environment has just seen so many more
iterations it's it's definitely a unique
environment and then Seattle is emerging
my first company was started in Seattle
we did not raise any money from Seattle
other than some angels who jumped in
after we had a term sheet but it's
definitely emerging they just haven't
been that many venture capital funds in
Seattle and I think that it has been
initially maybe more of a follower but
it's really exciting to see what's
happening now in Seattle because there's
an increasing number of venture funds
and more dollars in Seattle and the
nature of Seattle's history and tech has
been more enterprise and b2b so
therefore you know raising money for a
consumer business in Seattle with a
little bit harder and again that's
evolving so there's differences in
nuances I think geographically New York
investors are financial investors and
they do a lot of due diligence they ask
me questions I had never been asked
before that wouldn't make people in
Silicon Valley roll their eyes so it's
really interesting but I think the
differentiator about the fundraising I
have experienced is more relevant from
early when you haven't raised money
before verse
late when you've raised it before so a
good friend of mine is the CEO of procom
he said that Kristen we know who's gonna
lead our next round we don't know who
it's going to be but we know that person
we have a relationship with the person
who's going to raise who's going to lead
our next round and it was a really
interesting thing that he said because I
thought yeah that's right it's not I'm
not gonna go to a stranger at this point
because we have relationships but that
first round that first time you know it
was like beg borrow steal and I was also
28 years old so you know it was really
really hard and so to me that's just the
the difference is is geographical to
some extent as I described but I think
it's different strategies depending on
where you are yourself in your
fundraising evolution and then also
obviously where you are in your company
of course as well so how does in terms
of that strategy how does it work even
if you're raising you know a seed round
or a pre seed round or whatever you want
to call it everybody calls things
differently you know even even that's
early early first money you're talking
to a combination of individuals and to
institutional investors at one form or
another how do you do you change your
approach or do you do talk differently
to each of those sets of people how is
that how does that work I guess I I have
thoughts on this and being kind of in
the middle of it I am so I have a
background in political fundraising
because I was able to go out and raise
Kent money for candidates I believed in
which has been very helpful in this and
I think the main difference that I've
had to learn between raising from
individuals and raising from
institutions is that it is less of a
conversation when you're talking to
institutions I think I when I started I
kind of went in more conversational how
I am you know just me and I realized I
kind of said I took back after first you
sat back after first few pitches and
thought you know I I used to be a
litigator and I know what going into a
meeting like that is and being very
professional and talking about a deal
and I needed to go in and say this is my
business this is an opportunity I'm
giving to you to join something I am
building that will show incredible
returns is a great business and I'm a
really good CEO and this is the deal and
I love
to join me and that's it and I think
taking that approach has worked a lot
better for me it doesn't feel entirely
natural it's not how I approach
conversations with people every day but
this is this is a business conversation
and to present it as such and then also
I've learned the more the further I've
gotten into this and like I only have
nine months of experience in this and I
am NOT an expert but you have to nail
the numbers you need to know your
numbers inside and out you need to know
the model that you built why you put
those assumptions and how things can
change if you don't you know if say
there was a downturn how would it change
this or X or Y but you really need to
know your numbers you come across as
much more knowledgeable about your
business and you do actually know your
business better when you know the
numbers and I think that's something
that we don't talk about enough but that
really really knowing the numbers that
you're presenting inside and out is so
critical yeah that's definitely a sad
fact really when when when out
fundraising that women are held to a
higher standard in that and really
knowing in numbers inside out is
absolutely crucial because as soon as
you start wavering you lose the
confidence of the investors I'm gonna
just add something as someone who came
to fundraise doing very little relevant
experience so I'd been a professor right
I know how to teach a class but that was
pretty much it turns out I didn't know
how to build a medical device but so I
didn't have a list of people to go to
I'm in a second this spreadsheet warm
intros LinkedIn anyone who knows me
knows how much I hate social media but
LinkedIn is my best friend and I spend a
tremendous amount of time looking for
those looking for those warm intros that
can be made but when we first worked on
raising it we did it for years I mean
years talking to everyone the first
check came from a friend who had a
company and had gave us like their
supply closet basically turned it into
an office for us and he just saw us
working every day for years on end and
saw the terrible things that were
happening you know all the typical
stories you hear about investors they
all happened and he just watched us go
through it and he saw how dedicated we
were and that's that's where the first
check came from but my co-founder and I
we didn't know anybody with money we
didn't have any family with money we
don't have any friends with money well
turns out we didn't have one but you
know so I guess I what I want to say is
even when you're new at it and you don't
have it that existing network
perseverance is that's what you need
that's really all you need is that
perseverance story one quick story the
first ever check that was written was by
the guy had worked for for my first job
after college so I was a consultant and
he was the partner who started this
consulting firm for tech companies and I
you know killed myself for him I was
really I worked at sleep under the desk
and so forth and he and I was getting I
was an immigrant so I got a green card
through him and and actually that was a
huge deal because I was essentially a
prisoner in this company so I really
don't have a choice so I was I I really
did I but I was a person that made his
life okay because he didn't have to
sleep under the desk so I did that for
four years or something and then fast
forward I start this company with this
guy I went to college with and were like
here's our idea and he would and I went
his office with Glenn and we sat there
and I'll never forget he hand wrote the
check for $25,000 and he slid it across
the desk and he said don't lose my money
okay I was terrified actually I have a I
can't I really am the most responsible
with I can't stand the idea of losing
someone's money it's like Canadian
puritanical work ethic thing but I would
say that the lesson is that and that is
the first person that will write you a
check is the person who knows you I
think to the point of you were in their
supply closet or I was you know sleeping
under the desk to make his life better
so he saw what I was capable of and they
invested in they'll invest in you as
opposed to necessarily your company and
it's funny now I do some angel investing
and I invest in people you know people I
know really well and when they're
starting something it's sort of almost
doesn't matter what they're starting is
I know them that well so I think a lot
of angels to actually think about it
that way and I one quick thing to add to
this because we've talked about LinkedIn
for warm introductions you might kill me
for saying this but like Kristen ovni
Kieran who you will hear from later they
have all made introductions for me and
that's what your community will do for
you you are a female founder or this
tribe will help you you just have to ask
so I think it's been made fairly clear
here that fundraising is pretty hard
it's a long process and it has ups and
downs so how how have you learned to
cope with the lows of it and what
support networks have you been able to
leverage through that okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell my nightmare story I
won't tell that the nitty-gritty details
but there was a horrible thing that
happened just an investor was completely
inappropriate and it was in a Starbucks
on Mercer Island so it was really public
and I couldn't even get outraged and
then and I had to go then I had to take
the bus home afterwards and and so I'd
kept my composure in front of him and
then I got on the bus and I'm sobbing
and I'm just texting everyone I know
like is this normal this person said
these things and they're all like no
it's not normal and the next day I
walked in and my my co-founder I was
telling him about it and I'd been
texting with him and he said I want you
to write it down just write it all down
right now write the story down and it
was sort of this purging thing but
basically your network I mean the people
who support you and everything else in
your life they will support you through
through the lows because there will be
there will be lows I mean there's no way
around it everyone men and women
fundraising is really hard but it's also
crucial
I'd say other than a lot of red wine
my co-founder because there's nobody
else to party process with in that way
like we go to the party which was not
really a party we have the pitch and
then we process and we process it to
death and we wonder about the the you
know body language in the room and
whatever so for me I've never actually
I'm a co-founder I'm not a founder I
mean I'm just in my core I think I just
prefer to co-found things and so it's a
team and that for me has been my saving
grace
it you know there are days I do well it
processing in days I don't I think for
me that X knowing expectation is really
important that I'm going to here know
all of the time until I hear yes and
just accepting that and knowing that
it's absolutely not personal even though
it can feel like it changes the bar for
me I I am on my own pitching largely
which is somewhat different but I rely
on my team a ton to talk through things
with me to prepare me to bounce things
off of I talked to my family about it a
lot too because probably they wish I
wouldn't but I do and it's it's good and
you know I just I take time out to
exercise which is really important for
me and my own mental health and because
you can let this consume you 24 hours a
day and you should give yourself an hour
right you should give yourself an hour a
day I think that's really important and
you're going to hear horrible things
you're going to hear things that people
wouldn't say to men but it's really
equally as hard for men and women in
terms of the number of investors you're
gonna have to pitch to before you hear
yes so just a good attitude it was
really important and red wine okay so we
just have a couple of minutes left so I
guess for each of you is there anything
that you wished you'd known when you
were starting that you can you can share
with with the audience here so that when
they go off to do their fundraising
they've got that piece of advice in
their mind so there was a time with my
company where I was working to raise so
essentially for medtech you know we
raised this money to build a device
that's really expensive to commercialize
devices I should have raised more money
to commercialize it and I didn't and I
started and it was hard and I was like
oh I'd rather just talk to our customers
because they love me and and that's what
I did I let myself stop doing the hard
thing and then I did the comfortable
thing which was all work on sales
because I loved doing that and you know
that's where I get the positive feedback
and it's not where I'm getting the
relentless nose and that was a mistake I
should have stuck with the hard thing
now that would have been better for the
future
for the growth trajectory overcome
so don't be afraid of the hard things I
think for me it would be as I was going
out to raise the seed I wish I had said
I am going to start raising the seed on
this date and at that time I will have
my deck ready I will have my list of VCs
I want to approach ready and I will just
go and do it and I kind of dragged the
process out a little bit on the front
end of not having everything prepared
and starting to talk to people and I
think every time I go forward I'll have
my list of people I'm reaching out to
the dates I'm going to fundraise like
you make a business plan make a
fundraising plan I think that's the best
way to put it I'm gonna give you
something very tactical that I didn't do
before and I started doing in this
company which has been incredibly
helpful so the first few times you pitch
you're terrible and some pie so they say
go with the you know that's the right
way to say this they'll let the VCS that
seem like your least favorite Mary or
the less you know impressive I don't you
want to have some reps so don't have
those reps with an investor the only
other person under fundraising process
is an unfair equation because as
entrepreneurs we raise I've raised seven
rounds a venture it's a lot in a career
mostly you raised two or three right one
and in venture capitalists are in doing
many many more deals than that
so they've seen the picture before so
the only other person who can really
give you good feedback other than an
investor is a CEO who's raised money so
what I started to do is I do this like I
don't have four but all in one day I ask
my friends who are founders who have
raised money successfully to come for
45-minute junks and we pitched them and
we get in the room and there's no like
you know pretending it we they're an
investor and we are pitching them and we
go for 20 minutes or whatever and then
we get feedback for whatever those the
rest of the time is and they're like
relentless you know which is exactly
it's a gift that feedback is a gift so
we did that and in one day we pitched
whatever for CEOs who had raised a ton
of money and sold companies to Google
and like that value was so incredible so
find ways to do that I would just highly
recommend it
and then think about that feedback it
once you start actually pitching
investors the best you're not gonna get
a YES on your first pitch but you are
gonna get feedback so that's your goal
your goal is to get that feedback and
when you call them you don't say are you
gonna you know invest you say I really
want your feedback and they'll actually
respond better to that and you really
want to write it down and think about it
and ask people if it seems like good
feedback and weighed against the
feedback you get next time which is
completely the opposite of what they
said but really I mean keep it really
notes on your feedback because some
people don't learn as they go through
the process and each round is a learning
process even though you've raised before
so you have to just really think of
yourself as a beginner all the time okay
well I can actually talk about this for
hours but suddenly we've we've run out
of time so thank you very much to the
three of you for for sharing that
knowledge and giving that advice and I'm
hoping that that for you now who are
thinking about starting startups and
going out and raising that you have some
some really helpful information there so
yeah thank you again
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everybody my name is Amy I'm the
batch director at Y Combinator which
means I manage the founder experience
during the three-month program after we
make an investment in you guys
I'm also an executive coach with a
background in psychotherapy for the
founders during the batch so if any of
you have mental health tech things come
talk to me or email me Amy at Y
Combinator comm is Lucy from slide Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right everyone if you could take
your seats
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we might have sir
yes
we're going to start hurting step away
from the snacks
don't be afraid of the chairs in front
there's a few up here you our next
speaker Sharon Schneider who is the
founder and CEO of texty oh so I
actually started hearing about text EO
last year from a number of YC alumni who
use and love text EO so they use text
you to analyze their job postings so so
texting was used not only by startups
but also by large companies like Johnson
& Johnson and CVS and basically they
analyzed data from job postings from
around the world and they can tell you
which are going to be more successful
so text EO has been around for about
three years and they have raised twenty
nine point five million dollars which is
amazing and what I thought was really
cool a really cool detail about them is
that about 50 percent of their team is
female and female or non-binary and
their board is over half female as well
so before yeah I know that I think that
doesn't deserve a round of applause
and so before tech CEO Kieran held
product leadership roles at Microsoft
and Amazon so I'm really excited to have
you meet her today and so welcome Karen
hey um how many of you had heard of text
EO before today oh that's really
exciting
so I'm Kiran I am the founder co-founder
and one of one of the founders on the
CEO of tech co we're gonna go back a
little bit through my journey getting to
text EO and a little bit of our journey
as a company I'm gonna walk you through
today five really important decisions we
made that have massively accelerated us
as Kat just mentioned we're a series B
stage company we raised twenty nine
point five million dollars so far
and three years and three months ago we
didn't exist okay we were founded in
late 2014 thank you so you can do this
too right I'm gonna show you when you
leave today you'll guess I'm ready so a
little bit about me
whoops too fast there we go
those are some old pictures of me I grew
up with a dad who is an engineer he's 78
years old he's still running his own
company he's totally my hero right he
started it when he was 40 I started
textile when I was 40 so I've literally
seen the entire journey of his small
engineering company my mom was a writer
and I grew up to be an engineer and a
writer and very much formative and what
we do at xeo so when I went to college I
double majored in linguistics and math
which was a really present combination
that I didn't know would be present at
the time and then I continued on and I
got a PhD in natural language processing
and I met someone else here today who is
a graduate of the same program that I
was in so that's really exciting but
really my whole life in one way or
another from childhood all the way on up
was about the statistical measurement of
language with math I chose linguistics
because I didn't want to pick between
math and language I've always really
liked both I've been coding since I was
three I was really lucky to have a dad
who was an engineer so at my age it was
pretty unusual to have computers in your
house when you were three because I'm in
my 40s but we did I won my first science
fair project in fourth grade by writing
an early dating application that I mean
basic those of you who are old enough
where if you put in your name and
answered some questions about you it
would say the name of the person in the
class that you were gonna marry right
however the people didn't know about
if/then and go to so it was a really
great coincidence whenever the boy I had
a crush on put in his information it
said he was gonna marry me teacher was a
little suspicious I think
the other thing I did a lot as a kid was
I played sports I played sports forever
I still coach my three daughters in
basketball today but sports and teamwork
were a huge part of my upbringing and it
really gave me a major appreciation for
teamwork and tenacity so if you have
daughters get them into sports it pays
dividends forever um that's me as a
little kid that's me on the upper right
in middle school I've always had a flair
for performance with a mullet by the way
still it was willing to do that and
that's me in grad school with I I don't
know how much we had had to drink at
that party but as I came out of graduate
school I didn't know what I wanted to do
I spent a year just writing and ran out
of money and I had a friend at Microsoft
at the time who said I really think
you'd like working in technology you
should work in software I was like no I
hate all those people I went to grad
school with all those people and not
interested in he's like okay but you
said you needed a job I her out of money
like good point
and long story short he was right I am
absolutely a technology and software
person so I was at Microsoft for about
eight and a half years and it was a
really good experience for me
I was hired as a computational linguist
building spell checkers and grammar
checkers and by the time I left the
company my my culminating project was
leading bings native integration into
Windows across thousands of people so
really learned how to build software
always with the product and engineering
focus so when it came to text EO I
understood product
I understood natural language processing
and I didn't understand that much about
starting a business I mean you know my
co-founder and I who I will talk about
in a minute we're both technical
co-founders okay so everything to do
with sales and marketing and business
operations and fundraising was all
really really new to me I started
writing a lot when I decided to leave
big companies didn't know what I wanted
to do didn't know I wanted to start a
company of my own but a bunch of these
got some press I started blogging quite
a bit and I started writing a lot about
statistical measurement of bias right so
I did a study when I was at Amazon I
don't know if I was a very good employee
at Amazon because I mostly sat in
meetings logging how many times men and
women women interrupted each other and
then I published it in Slate her that
happy I published a piece right as we
were getting started that in unfortunate
on bias and performance reviews and
technology that was really fortuitous
because it went hyper viral and it ended
up formative in in tech CEOs history um
I blogged I had little comic strips of
me and my daughters that I drew on the
blog if that blog is still there but now
most of my blogging is that tech CEO um
but you know I was really writing a lot
so again always an engineer always a
writer when Jensen and I decided to
start tech Co we had a really clear
vision okay and I'll talk a little bit
about his background in a bit from
everything we had both done we had this
idea it had nothing to do with talent it
had nothing to do with hiring it had
nothing to do with bias still doesn't
but if anytime you wrote anything at all
okay just think about this for a minute
you're writing a pitch to an investor
you're writing a sales email you're
writing a job description which is
probably how you know of us if you know
of us if you knew ahead of time who is
going to respond that would be super
powerful right if anytime you were
writing you knew exactly which aspects
of your language we're getting one group
to engage while another walked away then
you could change your approach right you
could get a different result before you
published it not after you published it
and so this thing we've come to call
Augmented writing we didn't have that
language three years ago really means
writing supported by masses and masses
of data where you you know your engine
can find the patterns you know which
words which formats which constructions
get one group to engage while another
walks away that was really our founding
mission the very first thing we built
before before we had ever had funding
was a kickstarter predictor and
Kickstarter was a fantastic place to
prototype our technology because all the
projects are public domain and all the
outcomes are known so you can look at
the successful projects and the
unsuccessful projects and you have a
really good data set and so that on the
left is the first tech CEO uiv Jensen
our CTO drew that on a napkin
when we were in San Francisco and you
can see the first prototype we built
looks actually a lot like that and about
eight weeks into the company we had this
prototype working we got to 97%
predictive in minute one of a project as
to whether it was going to make money a
little depressing the quality of your
idea has no bearing on whether you make
money on Kickstarter not at all as a
longtime product person that was
actually a little demoralizing but the
fonts you use how long it is where you
place your video content how you caption
your video content many of these things
are highly predictive of success so that
was really interesting and it felt like
we were onto something really big which
is the way you communicate can sometimes
even be more important than what you
communicate in getting to a certain
outcome so nine weeks into text EO we
raised our seed round with us this was
never gonna be a business right it was
never going to be like we're ready to go
out the door where the go-to-market plan
of helping Kickstarter entrepreneurs
aren't enough of them to make that a
billion-dollar business but it proved
that we knew what we were doing and it
worked and so imagine you're in a room
with a bunch of investors and they all
by the way are familiar with Kickstarter
they all have a favorite campaign and
you're like so look it works no like no
no go find robot turtles how does that
one work what would you have said about
that no no go find you know the the
potato salad guy like what would it have
said about that so you have to do this
over and over again but it worked that
was our first office in another
co-working space that I will not name
here the Riveter didn't exist
and on the right up there those are the
monitors we bought for our team when we
got our seed round a one and a half
million dollars we made our teamwork
without monitors we worked without a lot
of things it was a huge day for us I
guess we bought monitors three years
later we just moved into a 25,000 square
foot space downtown and we're like oh
man this is big but that is you know
what we looked like in our beginning
which I'm sure for a lot of you who are
just getting started it's a lot what you
look like - so I'm gonna walk through
quickly five decisions that either I
made or we made together that I think
have accelerated our growth and
hopefully there's something useful in it
for you the first one may or may not be
repeatable but I started the company
with Jensen Harris who is our CTO he's
also my husband so you may not be able
to find that as a repeatable pattern so
that's our life right up in the left is
our like professional headshot which by
the way took a long time to get all of
our pictures will look a little like
family holiday photos and those are our
three daughters so we have three
daughters who are third grade second
grade first grade
yeah we're not we're not bored
Jensen's background is in always a
complement to mine so well I have been
deep in language and statistical
modeling and building software forever
Jensen was a musician he went to music
school but also like me had been coding
since he was three made his way through
college building shareware which again
like 20 years ago that was a thing and
really developed an industry-wide
reputation around user experience he
invented the first UI for email ever
right in the form of Outlook I led the
design and implementation of office
ribbon commanding in her face and then
Windows for the whole world so where I
had this experience you know really
understanding which how did how do you
use an LP machine learning to find
patterns in language I was really the
backend sensibility of the company he
knew how to build a user experience
truly for a billion people right we
didn't have a billion people we didn't
have a million people we still don't
have a billion people but you gotta
aspire there you got it you got to build
it so it's usable by people who are not
linguist not engineers not data
scientists the fact that we've done this
together wouldn't work for every family
but for us it is an incredible
foundation because there's no one I
trust more right so if he picks
something up I know it's good and if
it's not he's gonna tell me and vice
versa and we have very different
strengths so that's been a decision by
the way it didn't make it easier to
raise money the first time around
there's certainly some people who didn't
want to invest in us because we had you
know the family relationship that we
have didn't make a difference in the a
or the B so just remember that if you
get over the hurdle people look at what
you can do together and you have
investors kind of in your camp so
whether you're co-founding with your
spouse or not I really like what Kristin
said in the last panel co-founding is an
amazing choice solo founding I look at
what amy nelson is doing here with three
babies under four and she's a solo
founder and like hats off to you that is
hard co-founder gives you someone to
rely on and you need even if they're not
your spouse they're a little bit like
your spouse and you really need to have
that that trust so that's kind of the
first decision that really I think was
that how we got started that really
accelerated us okay
the second important decision was the
decision to start with job posts so as I
mentioned we got started we built a
kickstarter predictor has nothing to do
with talent or bias but remember I was
publishing quite a bit about really HR
documents and documents about people and
bias we knew and still know that in six
seven years from now when we IPO we want
you writing everything with text EO we
want you writing every single thing at
work with text EO it is a bold ambition
we are gonna take down Microsoft Word
and Google Docs and we can do it because
we've had the opportunity to run those
products you got to start small as a
start-up if you're making something
that's really really predictive right
that actually when you type in a word
processor cat talked about tech CEO is
analyzing job post is actually more for
writing job posts
you need to give guidance that
specifically works for the kind of
writing that is at hand
so we realized early we had a lot of
opportunity because I had a lot of
relationships and talent and HR because
of work I was publishing to do something
really good for that audience they had a
problem they're spending a lot of time
and money recruiting and making
recruiting content they're not happy
with how it performs both from a time to
hire perspective and certainly a
diversity and inclusion perspective they
had data about the problem so they have
a masses of job posts and they keep
track of how those job posed a key to
with real people and we had a technology
and so the decision to start with job
post was really essential so focusing
that broad vision in on a place where we
could deliver value for companies ok so
you could actually prove that the
platform works we had unique
relationships to get us started so if we
had started out in sales and marketing
which by the way every investor that we
first talked to asked us why we weren't
starting there because there's a lot of
money in sales and marketing we would
have been choked out right as the head
of an HR tech product I get to go meet
with CEOs of Fortune 100 companies
because they care about that problem and
it's a very underserved population
technologically if we had built
something in sales and marketing to
start I would have been just another
sales enablement CEO right so find the
place that is uniquely you that you can
win we started here because we thought
we could win deliver value and at the
same time it's had this stealth benefit
which is by the way in all of our
companies so you think about a company
like Apple or Cisco or Johnson & Johnson
because they're mostly an enterprise
product everybody in that company is
using text EO because every job function
hires and so when we're ready with
products for those other domains they
know us in fact one of our challenges is
people try to give us data for other
domains ahead of our desire to be in
those domains because remember your
startup we're still only 65 people right
you got to focus
you got to do something you can do
uniquely well and win so for us this was
a really good place to begin the series
B we raised last year is the REC
ignition that the platform works and
we're ready to start attaching it to
other kinds of writing and then of
course there's the wonderful benefit
that actually you can solve some really
significant bias problems for companies
to which is really important to us as
Kat mentioned our companies half women
are exact teams half women our board is
more than half women we live this let's
get through the third really big
decision we made is around rebranding so
in 2000 2014 that's what our logo looked
like and in 2016 we rebranded and it
really has very stark contrast before
and after the one on the right looks
like an enterprise product it wasn't
just about the look and feel though it's
also how we talked about the product so
our director of brand experience when he
arrives at the company observed that our
team when we were selling the product
was talking too much about how easy it
was to use and it is easy to use right
that's that's Jensen's contribution in
history but no one buys something
because it's easy to use no one gives
you a quarter million dollars for
something because it's easy to use like
a skateboard while skateboard about
example not easy to use like these shoes
are easy to use you buy it because of
the value it provides to you so he
really made the observation that we were
pitching the company and the product
wrong we were pitching about ease-of-use
which is our a strength of ours but
actually we should pitch the fact that
when companies use the product they fill
their jobs two weeks faster or they get
23% more women into the pipeline for
engineering and technology roles that's
why people buy the product and so all of
the rebranding and the way we talk about
the product have contributed to an
acceleration for us because people read
it differently you buy it when you saw
the value that was an important decision
the other thing I learned is somebody
with a product background is that the
product isn't only what you build it's
also how you package and sell it so when
we started out very first thing we did
was we had an invite-only beta we ran
that for 12 weeks once we got you know
five months into the company we had
built this beta for job descriptions we
had early
prospective customers who were sharing
data with us we figured that out the
beta went well and so we decided to
commercialize we didn't know anything
about how to commercialize so we did
what a SAS company might do is we're
like here go on our website you can buy
a seed of text EO for $59 a month or
something for yourself which is really
cheap for the value people loved it
because it was really cheap and they
went and they bought the product and
that was seemed really exciting until we
tried to get back into those bigger mid
market or Enterprise sales where they're
like well we could just buy like three
or four seats and we're good our team
can share them that's not good for
building a scalable business so we
shifted the model and today the way we
saw the product is with a flat fee
according to the number of jobs you have
open at the time you subscribe so if you
have a thousand jobs open you pay a flat
fee for 12 or for 24 months and you add
as many people as you want in fact you
should out everybody because the product
will work better for you as a
machine-learning company that's super
important to us because we're learning
from more writers in the platform and of
course in terms of our sustainable
revenue that's more important to us
because we shift the value away from the
individual writer to the value of the
platform what's it doing for your
company I can't even tell you again I
had no sales background at all I we were
our first six people were all technical
at the company I wrote a lot of the
original back-end of the product but I
was the only one who wanted to talk to
people just how I ended up being the CEO
and I certainly how I ended up being the
first salesperson so I ran sales
customer engagement basically for a year
before we hired our next person and you
can't imagine my shock the first day we
received a paper check in the mail for
$35,000 from my first enterprise sale
like what do I even do with a paper
check like it's it was 2015 I didn't
even know how to get it into our bank
account because it never occurred to me
people would pay that way it was like
sitting around the office like a hot
potato for a few days we were all like
oh my god someone's gonna lose it's
gonna go what are we gonna do most
people don't pay with paper checks
although
customer on their third year of renewals
still pays with paper checks luckily is
no longer my job to take care of the
paper check not where I excel but you
know this was a really important
decision for us changing the way we
licensed the product you can see what
happened in our a revenue graph you can
see the before and after you can see
that we were going along and then you
can see we're we went right up and our
customers were happier too because it
made sense to them they got it they
didn't want to have to limit usage
that's not good you want your whole
recruiting and talent and hiring team to
do it so pricing it in a way that made
sense to them and by the way allows them
to not worry about who they're giving
access to really worked for us so think
about when you first are licensing your
product remember that the way you price
it and license it is just as big a part
of the product itself as the actual
thing you're making really really
important we also figured out how to
make it a better value proposition for
our customers to share more and more of
their outcomes data with us the longer
their customers so they have a lot of
incentive to share data already because
the product works better for them and
they if they do right so they don't have
to just use everybody else as aggregate
model today tech SEOs job engine is
about three hundred and fifty million
jobs with outcomes attached so we're
adding about 10 million a month how do
you do that you do that with your
customers right the customers are our
deep partners in this and this was a
really important piece here which is
that they provide their data the
platform learns the guidance in the
platform gets better for them as they
write they use it we all measure
together again it creates this virtuous
cycle and if their data partners they
pay less to use the platform because
they're helping us make it they're part
of our family that's been a huge
advantage for us finally the press has
been really kind to us since we started
I think we because we got out of the
gate early showing some impact for
diversity and inclusion the press was
really excited I was writing quite a bit
so I
had some connections but one thing we
learned over our first couple of years
is that not all good coverage is
actually good for your business
so this is what the first some sampling
of what like the first year of texty
Opress looked like these are great
brands right you have the New York Times
writing about you Bloomberg writing
about you fortune writing about you
they're all writing about texty oh it's
awesome in a really narrow way they're
not telling the story of Augmented
writing they're talking about bias and
we care about bias we collaborated with
them on a number of these stories some
of them are based on blogs that we did
but we realized about a year into the
company that we're gonna deliver on the
bigger vision we need to change the
narrative we want these stories this is
important to us but we don't want to be
pigeonholed as a bias play that's not
what we are we're writing play so we
worked really really hard over the
following year or two and Marissa who's
our director of columns is here today
and really led a lot of this work to
change the narrative these are a couple
of examples of pieces we've had that
have broken pretty big we started
talking about other aspects of hiring
language we started talking about what
does it matter what does it mean if you
have grammar errors and your job post is
it gonna change their performance by the
way it doesn't I don't know if that's
good or bad it doesn't
we have piles of data about the public
job posts of every company in the world
and text EO knows the patterns that are
culturally distinctive in those
environments so and there's a lot of
Amazonians here but amazon jobs are see
if we can see it 33 times more likely to
contain wickedly and it's not all
wickedly prime but when you see things
like you know maniacal wickedly
fast-paced environment show up in job
posts it's not an accident if a bunch of
people in your company are using the
same language
it's your culture so we've started
telling bigger stories about writing and
culture and that's been really important
for us when I got to be on Bloomberg TV
last year I was talking about Augmented
writing what it means for the future of
digital writing
and yes we absolutely talked about the
fact that when Expedia's jobs are
gender-neutral they fill three weeks
faster that's awesome
right not an accident you reach the
whole population of course you find the
qualified person more quickly but people
are interested in us now for the bigger
story so we started small and we've been
broadening as we go um and you can see
just in the last six months since we
really brought this term big people are
talking about Augmented writing as the
category and it's the category we're
creating so this is fantastic this is
what we want it so hopefully there's
something in here you can learn from
if I were recapping I only have like a
minute left um pick that co-founder very
very thoughtfully if they're not your
spouse they're gonna feel like your
spouse my case I'm lucky because he's
actually my spouse and he's awesome
start small pick a problem that you
cannot only make traction on but you're
confident you have unique skills to win
because you know what if you don't win
early you don't win you got to pick a
place you know that you can win and then
be really mindful of the fact that your
product is also how you license it not
just what you build and the stories you
tell about yourself change how people
see you what they're willing to pay for
you and aim big don't let anybody put
you in a kind of a small box if you
start out in a small box because you're
trying to make progress that's a choice
you're making it's not a choice that
investors get to make on your behalf
it's not a choice that the ecosystem
gets to make on your behalf so thank you
thank you so in this next segment you're
gonna see a liver of some of the things
that we do at YC so at YC the founders
who go through the program do a lot of
one-on-one office hours with their group
partners so we're gonna have two of our
group partners from this batch adora
chung and holly lives they're going to
do office hours with one of the
companies that we picked from the
audience and then we're also going to do
something called we're gonna do a mock
investor pitch so another company is
gonna come up and they're going to pitch
Holly as if holly was you know and she
is an investor but she will pitch to
Holly and then we will give her feedback
on the pitch and adora will reap itch it
to show how she might pitch it if she
was the founder so welcome Holly and
adore on stage and then we'll get
started with on stage office hours hey
everyone how's it going all right so
this is amadora and this is Holly she
was the former founder of Kabam which
exited for over a billion dollars so
we're gonna bring your shot on stage all
right come on up
[Applause]
so go ahead and sit down
all right so great well just we're gonna
try to mock this office hours here all
right so can you just introduce yourself
to everyone in what are you working on
now there we go better cool I'm ami
satin Spinelli I'm co-founder and CEO of
earshot we developed technology that
uses voice analysis and machine learning
to provide people with feedback about
their communications so we have
technology that can listen to a dialogue
and provide some data analytics about
how effectively somebody is engaging
their audience in a conversation such as
the patterns of speech how much you are
talking versus the person that you're
talking to in an analysis of the
questions that you ask so what are the
what's the main application for this so
the reason that we developed this
technology was for teachers in an
educational environment and we developed
earshot for a feedback mechanism because
teachers are basically isolated in their
classroom they don't actually get
feedback on how effectively they're
teaching so I'm a teacher how would I
use this so you turn on your ear shot
app that's on your smartphone you'd
record yourself teaching and then after
class you'd get some data analytics on
your phone about certain key performance
indicators that are tied to effective
teaching and engaging students in skills
like critical thinking and
communications curious what kind of KPI
is like what are those yes so these are
based on research in the education field
that shows for example if you're a
teacher after you ask a question you
actually want to wait three to five
seconds before you elicit an answer from
students most of us are uncomfortable
with silence and we want to fill those
gaps but actually if you leave more time
it allows for deeper thinking and
broader participation so more a wider
range of students will
dissipate and if you want to focus on
critical thinking skills you're giving
time for thinking so have you have you
put this in the classroom what hasn't
been a feedback from teachers and yeah
what have you found out so far yeah so
we're we have a beta version of our
software and we're pilot testing it in
some schools and districts and what
we're finding is that there's really a
lot of enthusiasm for this type of data
it's really needed it's used by schools
who do teacher coaching or when teachers
go through colleges of education to
perform better these are kind of metrics
that are collected manually by people
and they take a lot of time so
automating that process is very valuable
however I'm the business problem that I
was hoping to kind of raise with you
during this office hours is I think my
offering is not broad enough to go to a
school directly I think I'm solving a
very niche problem we've made a very
deliberate decision to go very deep in
the analysis of questions for example
and that's not a broad enough offering
to sell into a school or district
usually they buy like a professional
learning system and so we're considering
pivoting our business to a b2b kind of
back-end licensing of technology so I
might have missed this but how many
teachers how many classrooms are you in
right now
about a hundred a hundred of them and
right now once you've gotten to the
district level are any of them
concentrated in a particular school or
they just spread out we have two school
districts who are licensing our
technology so among those districts they
have a handful of schools they eight
schools apiece who are using it and then
we have a handful of other schools as
well as individual teachers using it and
are they currently paying for this some
of them are yes so what about at the
district level what kind of feedback are
they giving you because that's where you
want to pivot to right so I think what
we wanted to pivot to is actually not
the district I think my hypothesis right
now is that I need to license my
technology to others that are already
selling into school districts and being
a technology behind their offering so
have you though talked to I mean but
what's the feedback then directly from
the school district have they
said it's narrow like what's causing you
to think like I gotta move out of this I
think we are not seeing the uptick in
usage that we'd like to see because
teachers have to do a lot of things in
their job and and they have to get these
o'clock hours for their professional
learning and so what districts tend to
buy are like a complete system that has
a lot of content and resources and we
don't really fit into that model so we
would be a great add-on to a model like
that if you're a publisher and you're
providing resources for teachers to
learn to be better teachers providing
data and analytics along with that
content might make sense so then your
new customer Knight might not be school
districts they're actually publishers by
later you might have a question of like
how they even got to find you once you
get like that's a whole suite of content
there right so how are they gonna even
turn on your voice app alright right
well my question is really around like
how do i revise my model to a b2b
licensing type model there's just a lot
of questions in there for me like when I
think about an end user I understand
that experience but when I think about
if my customer is another business that
to me is a completely different way of
thinking about my business like what's
the value to that business what's the
value proposition how do i price it how
do i license it all those kinds of
questions just just so we don't I just
go back a little bit I just want to push
on it sounds like what you've created it
is like an automated coaching on the
automatic coach for teachers to help
them be more effective and so I just
wanna make sure before we before you
pivot that actually to make sure you
don't actually have something big here
because it feels like something huge
here yeah if you can get test scores
like you can like increase this test
scores of students in a classroom by one
or even like even just one standard
deviation that would be huge for schools
and schools should theoretically pay for
for this right right so you're in a
hundred classrooms already said right
that is actually a lot
have you gone to have you sat in one of
those classrooms just for you know for a
week or even a month to see the
interaction and how the teachers are
actually using it and where are the
points like what is the point in which
the teacher and the user flow is like
just falling off and where you think
that you know they won't pay for it
mm-hmm so that's a really good question
I have certainly not sat in a classroom
with a teacher for a month I've done it
ad hoc here and there but haven't really
invested that kind of time and I think
that's a really good idea and I think
that what tends to happen is part of it
I think is
I think we're ona okay and so I think
that what happens I think what happens
is um teachers just get busy and they
kind of forget to turn it on and they
don't necessarily have the pressure of
being motivated to use it I think it's
actually a pretty deep philosophical
question that we could all ask ourselves
like I want to be a better speaker or I
want to be in better shape but am i
doing the things everyday that I could
be doing for that or I could just get
busy in the other things that I have to
do and so I have to cram all this
content into my students because they
have standardized test coming up and I
don't have time to think about how I'm
communicating with the students I the
pressure that I'm having is about the
test scores for example okay so the
problem with the teachers is they have
as you've identified they have just too
many other things to do and so adding
one more thing into their workflow is a
mess okay so one just to clarify all
they're doing to collect the data is
turning on something right to collect
speech okay and two is were you pushing
reports to them or it sounds like you
are trying to it sound like you're
trying to get and that you were getting
in the way in the sense that during a
class you were trying to tell them
something in the middle of it to help
them do something better or was it at
the end of the day it'd be like a report
card you gave to them so they keyed used
for the next day it's the latter so they
get a report and it'll pop up a little
alert on their phone when it's ready but
if they're still teaching they'll just
look at it when they have a prep period
or after the end of the school day
there's a little bit of time for a
processing so after you record you don't
immediately get your data there's a
little bit of time that lapses when the
school is responsible for test scores
like increasing making this test course
better everyone I think the teacher the
principal the superintendent who's gonna
get fired if the test scores are bad
the principal or the superintendent so
it is your software actually has it
proven to increase scores at this point
a to early stage I mean if you think
about it there's like a whole series of
behaviors that we know that this works
to better engage students there's
research that shows when students are
better engaged they perform better but
there's kind of all these steps along
the way and it will probably take years
for an efficacy study to be able to
connect directly use of this technology
with performance on a test score now we
can say other things that are interim
like when teachers use our technology
they talk less they ask better questions
they allow for a better wait time so
we're kind of inching our way there to
show these are metrics that researchers
have proven that are important steps in
effective teaching but we haven't quite
gotten to like this class use the
technology and a year later the students
test scores were higher than they were
the previous year could you not get to
that like do it for a year in one class
and do like just two classes one control
and whatnot and be able to get those
answers and I should probably add that
our funding to date in part has come
from grants from the National Science
Foundation and we're in the process of
applying for another one to do a study
like that but the economic buyer here is
clearly the principal as Holly noted
because they're going so I would be
selling to them and trying to and then
having the principal force the teachers
to actually use the system and then
doing what she suggested or what you
both suggested which is doing the
compare and contrast the control study
and I think the thing because you're so
early you should do things that don't
scale in this case it's actually just
being in the school's making sure that
that the teachers actually we're going
through like seeing their sports and
reading the reports but ultimately it's
back to the principal I think I think on
your second your second or your first
question about the BTB model I would it
seems like really passionate about
education and helping students improve
so I would focus on that more than you
know how do I use the voice data tech
stuff and do something else because then
that just becomes a what we call just
but like a solution in search of a
problem
and and you you'll end up doing
something you don't want to do and not
passionate about so if this if this
other thing doesn't work out then I
would just go all the way back from
square one and think like what do I
really want to do in this world
instead of fortunately tech come on to
what you want to do but but I think you
actually have something here it's just
doing things that don't scale for a
little bit longer so the next thing
we're going to do is bring up flavor
cloud who is going to pitch Holly who is
the investor here and then go from there
yep so I guess we're gonna be sharing
sorry so I'm gonna be an angel investor
and I've done some angel investing in
the past so I've only heard a little bit
about what you do and so we're just kind
of gonna mock what I would end up doing
as an angel investor so tell me about
flavor cloud Holly fabulous to meet you
and I want to tell you all about flavor
cloud what we do is we make
international purchases on any
retailer's website as easy as shopping
on Amazon so cheaper faster and
completely friction free so what
retailers would do is use our service in
their shopping cart and they can just
instantly ship to 220 plus countries
around the world so help me understand
because I've never worked at Amazon or
places that serve retailer so if I'm a
retailer like maybe I own like a Shopify
store you guys are I would I would go to
you to buy my raw materials we do the
shipping logistics and customs and
duties calculation for retailers so that
if you're in
Zoomer if you purchased from an
international website one of the
difficulties that you have is that the
shipping cost can be like huge right and
then the other issue that you can have
is that the customs and duties are
things that you find later on when you
actually get the product and in addition
to that you have to do additional
documentation you didn't expect that and
finally let's say you actually got the
product and now you're not happy with it
and you want to return it as a consumer
you're pretty much left to your own
devices and so what we do for retailers
is say that you know you figure out your
marketing strategy to get to you know
these all shipped to all these different
countries and what we'll do is the
underlying plumbing to make that happen
it seems like you're making shipping oh
there's another one
so I I own an online store and I want to
ship it to somebody in Wisconsin I would
use you guys that's right so no not
Wisconsin this is the International
shipping right so this is cross-border
commerce okay so if I want to Australia
somebody in Australia I had bought my
shoes that I designed and loved yeah
then so currently what would I do now I
would just force the consumer right I
mean that's what I would have Majan so
today is that most retailers in the last
two years have seen that because of
Amazon and because of you know social
media like Instagram and snapchat and
all of that consumers are directly
finding these brands and they're like
okay I want to go buy this right and
then the retailer says I'm not I don't
I'm not equipped to ship to you because
you're located in China or you're
located in Sweden or wherever it is
right and it used to be that it was 10%
of a retailer's business was
international in just the last three
years what what has happened is that it
has become
a one-in-three e-commerce purchases our
cross-border right so if you don't do
that you miss out on 40 to 60% of the
international traffic that comes to your
website in the u.s. it's about 40% if
you go to like China or EU it's well
over 60% of the traffic that's internet
so currently like how many dollars does
that translate to that's a trillion
dollar business by 2020 serving a
billion consumers worldwide okay so how
I mean right now then I feel like it's
DHL that I get international packages
from or eventually USPS and yes
certainly I could get it in three to
five days if using DHL and then like 21
days is like the slow boat Express like
how are you guys set up to be able to
compete with those yeah
great question to pay like 25 bucks as
the end consumer right so great
questions so what we talked about was
the consumer experience of you know how
hard it is to do international but what
we do is we're a b2b SAS platform right
we have suite of services that you can
plug in there's ap eyes and plugins for
Shopify and merchants right so what we
do for these guys is three things one we
integrate with a hundred plus carriers
around the world so that's our logistics
platform we have an algorithm that goes
across that network of carriers and says
what is the cheapest fastest most
efficient way to move this product from
point A to point B which is across
country borders right and it takes
historical performance for that route
and also specific to the product to come
up with the recommendation just right
off the bat because we have these
contracts with these carriers and it's a
volume-based play across a whole suite
of retailers you're looking at like 80
plus percent savings on shipping so
imagine if you go as a customer today on
this website and you have a shipping
cost of $60 if you go with us you have
$10 shipping and you're like okay that
increases your conversion rate right off
the bat the second thing that we do for
retailers is
we have a customs engine so let's say
you have thousands of SKUs or even
millions of SKUs right if you're an
enterprise retailer the real nightmare
with international is that you have to
classify every single product and come
up with this weird code and that defines
what the duties are and the paperwork is
a massive pain in the ass and so what
happens is you have to as a retailer
have a logistics team that understands
the inherent details and that's a huge
cost that most retailers don't
understand how far along are you like
how are you set so we we actually
started with a vertically integrated
marketplace in 2014 what does that mean
that means we enabled through our
marketplace small and medium sized
businesses sell to consumers worldwide I
started that because as an end consumer
I had problems purchasing from these
international websites so we created
that and initially it was three markets
US UK India and then we started
experimenting with this and we figured
out with 300 plus brands that we scaled
to 100 plus countries worldwide and we
found that this anywhere to anywhere
logistics infrastructure that we had
built became the one that they were most
interested in and we started getting
requests for brands that didn't want to
be in the marketplace but still wanted
to use our technology so then what we
did was we took the back in and said
we're gonna create the SAS
infrastructure and make it such that you
know you can simply plug and play so you
don't need to worry about any of these
other aspects of - you have about 300
brands on your site using that to our
own marketplace it sits on top of our
infrastructure and last year we made the
pivot to the SAS platform that was in
the summer and then before the holidays
we started onboarding customers to our
Shopify plugin and we have a dozen
customers for two quick questions like
how much is like how much shipping
volume have you done through your
platform so we did about a hundred KGMB
through our shipping classroom
for the external customers 6% Commission
so basically on order value okay so
that's been our revenue outside of the
marketplace and we have a pipeline of
customers it's been really great the
feedback that we've gotten so we're
looking at 10x in the next four months
okay and sorry I lied it's actually
three questions total many competitors
yes so it's you think you guys are the
ones that are gonna so the competitors
this is kind of a greenfield space
because cross-border Commerce has grown
in the last two years and we've seen the
trends happen in the last two years the
biggest competition is a company called
Pitney Bowes they have a solution called
water free it's a 2.5 billion dinosaur
company but it's also dinosaur
technology it is geared towards it's
something that customers hate and it's
geared towards a market by market kind
of implementation which is very
prohibitive for the smaller companies
and your other question was about so
basically what makes us better in this
sense and why we are best equipped is I
actually spent 10 years in supply chain
logistics working with carriers UPS DHL
you know all the guys that you mentioned
I built customs integration solutions
but I also built route optimization
solutions but more so from the other
side of it so I inherently understand
the problems and then with my co-founder
at Microsoft I built enterprise
solutions it's our very last question
which I usually ask is how much are you
looking to raise and at what valuation
so we've raised 1.2 million in two
rounds seed round so far my second round
is halfway through and I'm raising
another million for the next nine months
and that valuation do it's ten million
right now valuation cap pre I'll get
back to you thank you can you send me
the deck yeah oh yeah very nice meeting
you thank you
[Applause]
hi I'm and worse not how are you I'm
Holly you founder of clever cloud cloud
sorry Laver cloud tell me a little
flavor cloud is stripe for international
shipping so online merchants in under
five minutes can they just plug it into
the online check flow and or checkout
flow and voila every they can do
international shipping and deal with
customs and everything
I mean you handle the payments and yeah
just payments to no we don't do the
payments we we just so how it works is
the the merchant will send us through
our API the customers address and then
we automatically real-time determine the
best routes and the best price to ship
it to them how like how big of a problem
is this right now so right now what one
if you want to do international shipping
as a u.s. merchant typically what you do
is you hire really expensive consultants
who spend weeks if not many months many
many months charging an hourly rate
[Music]
trying to figure out all the different
combinations for first my last mile
customs customs is worse for all these
types of countries and even when they
finish with that it's you know typically
there's still issues packages still get
lost everything still gets stuck in
customs and so it's just one big hassle
and that's if you can even afford it so
I think the problem is any anybody in
the US any merchant who wants to sell
goods to anyone in the world will be
using us very soon that's a pretty big
market so where are you guys
so big I can't say it so how far long
are you guys so we launched in 2014 and
the reason why we started working on
this is because we launched as a
marketplace for all sorts of brands and
retailers who were selling through us
and what we realized while they were
selling goods through us which was great
and it was going well their major
problem was international shipping and
so we decided we would solve that
problem for them and then as a result we
just decided to work on that problem
itself because it was big enough so I'm
gonna ask the elephant in the room like
what about Amazon why couldn't they set
this out because you know what they have
they have shipping locations all around
the world they're just going to
Australia - what oh okay so I mean
Amazon is a great way to distribute your
product but I think every every merchant
some a lot of merchants actually don't
work through Amazon them but I think
every every every brand for sure want
still to have their own site and
actually when you for Amazon
it doesn't actually cater to all
international customers and so in fact
if they use us we have a bigger
distribution than them yeah because we
cater to everybody in the world it's
good point I mean if you're in
Antarctica have you shipped so what like
what other competitors aren't there
outside of a Amazon like I can see what
retailers may not want to go over here
but there's got to be somebody else
that's cracking this or what what yeah
yeah I mean so they're they're there
other that there are a few other
startups that are taking taking a crack
at it but what we do well is we
aggregate everything so most of the
startups are taking a very fragmented
approach so they can only ship to one
country or you know they're trying to
build up something you worried that
they're going to do what you're gonna do
and like what makes you guys kind of so
I have ten years of experience in
logistics working at UPS and other
various places and so what I know very
deeply is I know the the the people are
doing the delivery but companies doing
delivery I know how to talk
to them and we've developed an out many
algorithms to put this all together so
how much are you looking to raise and at
what valuation I am looking to raise a
million dollars and our valuations 10
million dollars what are you looking to
use with that money so right now our
team is very very small and so we need
to expand our engineering team and we're
looking for people to help on the
operation side okay well how about this
why don't you go ahead and send me the
deck I'll take a look at it are there
any references but as well yeah
we have customers we work with over 300
brands already so you can talk to them
what do you what do you think how
interested are you in this well so I'll
be honest I've never invested on a
shipping logistics type of company so I
don't really have as much of a
background on it but what's very
interesting is this is like could be a
very big business when I could get a
piece of that so usually I'm looking for
something that can give me greater than
10x returns my check sizes usually range
from 100k to 250 K so I'll want a
certain percentage of the company as a
result of that and I want to be able to
keep pro-rata rights as I go further
okay so that definitely up for
discussion are around his half-filled
and so we expect to close in about two
weeks so I'll show you the deck and
hopefully we can chat further very very
soon thank you very much
[Applause]
I'm taking that check yeah I think I
think my biggest point feel ACK is
probably just shortening the
explanations of what you do I can see
you have a huge huge vision for this
which is great but I think just being a
little bit more succinctly your
one-liner I forgot what it was you said
stripe for logistics and I'm lucky
enough to know what stripe is but you
know even if it didn't have to like
sometimes a 4 B doesn't totally work I
should have asked you I said I said
stripe for international shipping and I
assumed you're a tech investor so it did
take me it did take me that's one of the
things I have a problem and in the sense
that I've said depending on you know
whether they know it I said flex support
for b2c e-commerce but that only works
with some folks and I hate to say Ober
for like you know International shipping
visit is like you could just say you
were an API I mean stuff with the stripe
analogy there is any easy easy like five
minutes to explain minutes to piñas
checkout flow easy and you're doing a
ton of work in the back but no one else
sees it yeah yeah I also I was a little
tripped up on like I kind of knew you're
selling to retailers but like for me I
just personally couldn't like figure out
the what at what it was that's why I
spent a ton of time just like okay what
it what is this thing
and that's mainly we're just more the
bulk of it and then once I could figure
out that they obviously had a ton of
questions afterwards too
yeah and this is a reminder for everyone
actually you you you asked the question
which I was hoping you wouldn't ask the
question but a lot of people actually go
to meetings with to investors and don't
ask for money like you just end with it
without asking and even if it's awkward
just ask it with confidence and I mean
the worst they'll say you know is but
you'll take all these meetings anyway
and a lot of people will say no so don't
worry about that Bart and I will say
this a lot of times what happens and I
didn't probably mock it to you well it
is usually the first question I asked
for is like how can I help is usually
what I asked that person and then so
it's true the entrepreneur has to guide
it to I'm asking for money this is what
I'm looking for and I think what door
did what on the founder side definitely
ask what the investor is interested in
this might not even be their domain you
might not even want them it could be
like a bad investor what is their check
size what are their expectations how
fast can they move do they need to talk
to somebody else but overall you do
really well
she's raising money is are there any
investors in this audience yeah that
sounds really cool there we go two to
three over there okay all right cool
all right thank you so much thank you
thank you so much
so Doron Holly can stay up here because
it's now time for the YC partner panel
hi everyone I'm Sharon Pope I work at YC
I run marketing programs and I want to
just remind you that you can submit
questions so go to slide o comm SLI do
comm if you don't have a question you
particularly want to ask you can upvote
someone else's and i'm taking the
questions from you so please if you
haven't yet go ahead and submit and I
will just stand great no I like standing
are we okay with me standing good okay
oh and the slide Oh event code is FFC
thank you Amy
slide Oh comm event code FFC all right
so starting off this was one of the more
popular questions that's come through so
far for female founders who have
families are there remote options for YC
or what options are available for
participating in YC if you don't live in
Silicon Valley oh yeah so recently we
put out something called the YC family
user manual actually Amy and Sharron
worked really closely on that and so
it's essentially we give it to all our
founders when they join the batch and
it's tips and advice for people who have
families on how to balance that
resources they can use and so what we've
seen a lot of both moms and dads come
through I see and they've all you know
sort of made it work in different ways
and so we've seen folks who have you
know there have been cases where they
brought the whole family they've been
cases where they've kind of commuted
back and forth
is there anything so the short answer is
it is not a remote program and part of
part of it is the benefit of building
that trust building that interaction
seeing that feeling that live I just
think it's honestly and the word strong
but a bit of a lost opportunity I was
gonna say waste if you don't come there
so we actually have an international
founder in our group she just had a baby
is six months old and she is doing a
company in Mexico
and if we have a ton of international
founders that actually fly back and
forth mainly because the business is
over there and then they come over for
the dinners and the group office hours
because it's just so much important for
her business to kind of move forward so
we have a lot of support stuff like the
user family manual that comes I've
definitely seen there's another group in
my in my batch right now
he brought his three month old son and
three year old I'm like here all the
parks you could go to here are all the
other things you could go to
particularly for women who there's a lot
of support also as well for nursing moms
there's also a really good blog post by
a female founder YC who talked about
making it work particularly while she
was nursing so it's just it just is a
lost opportunity if you're just not
there I will say that well we'll make
sure to tweet that article out so people
can after after the conference we'll
share it out so everyone can take a look
um so what another question what
industries or technology is does YC
think are extremely promising right now
so one of the things I think that is
exciting about what YC is that we get a
lot of applications every six months and
we get to see sort of it's like seeing
into a crystal ball so ideas from some
of the smartest most creative people
around the world come to us and so I
think some of the best ideas that we've
ever funded and some of the best ideas
out there aren't even things that we
would necessarily think of it's just you
know what you're all working on that we
get to get insight into that said there
are trends there's a really great blog
post at one of our partners put out if
you look up to startup site-geist and it
shows eight years of data from YC
application so it's shows sort of the
trends that we've seen like in 2011 we
saw a ton of Bitcoin applications you
know in about two years ago everyone was
building chat BOTS or things on top of
slack and so I think that's the most
exciting parts of what we do it's not
calling what's going to be the next big
thing but getting to I get see into
no a little bit into the future of what
might be so in terms of ideas too that
have come to mind one is retail and in
particular I think brick-and-mortar is
trying to go online now and online pure
plays are trying to figure out
brick-and-mortar there's like a clash of
cultures there and no one has really
figured that out so I think there's a
lots to do there in women's retail and
all and all these all these categories I
think I mean obviously Amazon's a big
player on the online retail and they're
trying to move off line too but I think
there's a lot of room there for lots of
startups to win there and then the
second one is I actually haven't I feel
like it's a little bit like blockchain
but like voice apps so every home like
almost every home now has an Alexa or
Google home or one of these things
there have been no great applications
like the biggest thing that people use
it for is just information retrieval or
reminders or stuff like that but the UX
is quite odd and it's it's not how we
let how we as adults like are used to
using things so I think there's a lot of
user UX stuff to do there and figure out
what that what those apps will look like
but yeah I think we I think everyone
thinks that like watch-chain voice is
the future but no one is figure out
great applications for it and so I'm
always curious when people are working
out what this could be the other thing
is you know we've talked a bit about how
we have applications from all sorts of
technologies and we actually put out
what we call a request for startups
which talk about some of the things that
maybe you know we'd love to see
applications from but one thing to bear
in mind is just because what you're
working on
isn't one of those that doesn't mean
that we're not looking for it you know
we want you to tell us what we should be
interested in
so don't kind of self select yourself
out because it's not one of the things
that we mentioned it's something that we
that we hear people saying well YC isn't
looking for companies like mine and we
totally are because we're just looking
for great companies so related question
a lot of people are asking about what
quality
the companies and founders you find most
attractive and also the red flags in an
application I feel like we addressed the
company's question but Kersey you've
seen a thousand companies go through
what what is it about founders in terms
of what you look for but also red flags
I don't think because we're looking at
so many of these companies at such an
early stage we're really really focusing
in on the founders themselves and so we
want to see people who are determined
who aren't going to give up the minute
that things get a little bit tough
particularly where there are teams of
co-founders we want to be able to to see
that there is some existing relationship
there and it's not just somebody that
you met in a coffee shop two weeks ago
and brainstormed for two hours and it's
all going to be amazing you know as
you've heard from from pretty much
everybody today you know the co-founder
relationship is so incredibly important
because it's it's something that will
get you through the lows and the highs
and you know they will understand what
you're going through you'll understand
what they're going through and one of
the number one reasons that we see
startups failing is actually that the
the founder relationship breaks down so
a lot of the things that we're looking
for in the applications are around do we
think the founding team is going to be
that that really amazing team that can
that can make this work a one tell we
have in that way as we look at the
equity split so we like to see teams
that have as close to equal equity as
possible between the co-founders and and
that's because you know even if someone
came up with the idea and was working on
it six months or so before you know
sometimes we'll see you know I came up
with the idea so I have 80% and my
co-founder has 20% but the reality is a
vast majority of your company's like
life is in the future it takes it I
think on an average of 10 years now to
IPO or exit so you want the co-founders
to be on as equal footing as possible if
I could sum it up in one word like
founders that are just formidable like
I'm like okay they're just gonna do it
regardless regardless of what happens
here in this room in the interviewing
room and I think that that's one of the
things that we find and we love to find
I will touch a note on two things
one around the technical co-founders so
and having teams we do love teams but
we've accepted solo founders as well we
accepted non-technical founders as well
but the reason why we anchor against
those is it's only three months that YC
is happening and if you don't have
somebody that can actually build and do
something then you're losing time on
learning and it's really really
difficult and finally I was I was
talking to action on meow I'll pick on
you we were like when you're in a
particular space particularly if it's
very crowded I'm very interested in like
what types of insights do you have like
I was talking to off me about her
insights I was like wow that totally
makes sense increasing the village on
child care and that I think is just
something if you're thinking about - I
have another question for you adore as
well alright so the next question so
we've talked about knowing your numbers
and how it's so important but maybe it's
even more important for female founders
so adore when you're considering an
investment are considering an applicant
to YC what metrics are you most focus on
what do you think are the most important
ones - that they're tracking and that
they know rock-solid
well if if they haven't built anything
yet there's I guess nothing to really
look at except for just understanding
what the market opportunity is - is
they're starting to build you know one
of the things that we tell every founder
is you should instead of growing really
really really fast the first thing you
should do is build a product that people
really really love and so that can be
defined as you know that so so then I
would say the question is what are the
metrics that define what happy engaged
users are happy engaged users getting
continuous value out of the product and
so it's it's different for every single
company but usually you can get like
three to four key metrics that kind of
give you a 360 over overview of what
that means so it could be like weekly
active users NPS retention is a huge one
you should always be looking at
retention meaning you know five you know
100 people came this month how many
stayed the next month and so and so
forth and so that's that's a
quantitative way to look at it and so we
would always probably ask for those kind
of metrics and then the more qualitative
is like when you're talking to people
you can kind of get a feel of you know
how you know how good your product is
already or how much they value it so for
example if they should
if you say if you ask them Oh what you
think and they're like oh that's pretty
cool that that's that doesn't feel like
you know they're happy engaged but if
they're like oh my god Holly how can I
get an invite link so I can send it to
20 of my friends now like there's a huge
difference there and so that's a more of
a qualitative thing that you can get out
of that and I think to omni's point
earlier is there like it she was saying
you have seven weeks until the
application deadline so start and start
tracking and make some progress do you
think that there's is there a period of
time you look at in terms of the metrics
or is it I'm small um it's this entire
period when you start at building and
started using and just you want to see
some growth in terms of you know your
MPs is getting better your weekly active
users are getting better and I mean the
metrics tell you the what and but you
need to deep dive and know what the why
so that you can continue doing the
things I keep working
maybe I'm surprisingly a question maybe
Kat will answer um this room wants to
know if YC will ever have a Seattle
office or accelerator I think for now
and I travel a lot internationally all
around the US and I think for at this
point in history it still helps most
companies to spend three months in the
Bay Area there is just it's so easy to
raise money there there's a huge no I
mean it's relatively relatively I mean
you know it's hard but it's much easier
than pretty much anywhere else in the
world and then there is just ever you
know a huge network of founders and so
spending three months building that
network of investors and other founders
who can help you out as you grow I think
makes sense and then you can come back
and and bring that network and all that
knowledge with you back here or back you
know wherever your users are the one
thing I my sort of hope is the way that
we get you know organically get Y C's
all over the world is that we fund a
really incredible company you know they
grow Pompey I'm looking at you or shift
labs they grow they become
billion-dollar companies and their
founders start reinvesting in the
ecosystem so that you know they start
investing in the founders here and so
that's I think the most my dream for YC
long-term is that it's the alumni in
each of these regions that sort of grow
the whole community
I think that's great so question and
obviously we've seen some great YC alums
on stage today
how does YC interact with founders after
YC so it's a fairly common misconception
that people think that YC ends after the
three-month program and actually that's
not true at all because we are still
investors in your company and and we're
here to help you know we want to help
the founders that have been through the
batch already and so we're here as a as
a resource we're always available to ask
answer questions whenever founders come
back to us and so some examples of
things that we we help with after the
the batch you know the maybe the
founders have raised a million dollars
out of demo day and they're now a year
past that and they're thinking about
starting to raise their series a and we
can come and we'll help them pull
together a pitch deck will help them
with their practice pitchers we you know
will we'll introduce them to people who
could be helpful and then continuing on
we also now have later stage program
where we work with companies who maybe
have 50 employees or a hundred employees
and and how do we how do those companies
scale and how can they you know what
sort of problems are they coming across
that we can help with and so the idea is
is that we are always a resource for you
know everybody who's been through YC and
so any of our any of our experience if
we can be helpful we we want to be
helpful to you and on the backend we've
built a lot of software so we have
something called book face it's like
it's like face book meets LinkedIn meet
Sakura where all of our founders sort of
everyday are sort of talking to each
other asking questions helping each
other out and I think more often then
you know founders will come to us
occasionally if they have questions
especially around fundraising but I
think more often they're asking their
community the community of founders to
help each other out so that's I think
those touch points happen on a monthly
basis if not more yeah
I will just chime in and say another
misconception is that ycs about the
three months and so and this doesn't
necessarily you don't have to take him
up on it but office hours are open for
any founder for any partner afterwards
and so for me two years out of YC I
actually take away more value out of
that then even during the period when it
was very intense and there's a lot of
stuff and you're mostly working with
your group partners there are people
that have experience across the board
there are former venture partners their
former founders obviously they're from
everything across the board and so for
me when I talked about Mentors most of
my mentors are actually YC partners and
so the ability for me to every month or
whatever it is own reaching out to them
and having that has been so invaluable
so for those of you that are kind of
evaluating YC as a program don't ever
think about it as just like a
three-month thing it's sort of like a
lifelong you get into this tribe of
people and founders that I think is just
so invaluable Thank You Avenue founder
of poppy I love that so I think that and
this is obviously something that
actually I think if Holly on adora want
to take this one so as a founder how do
you keep the momentum going when the
funds are running dry and growth is
getting really challenging or maybe I
guess I guess if it would help to put a
finer point on it can you talk through a
time where you felt that crunch and how
you were able to push through it whether
it was fully dry or super depressing so
I started we started a company in 2006
exited in 2017 and 2008 was the worst
year ever for all startups everywhere
around the world but particularly in
Silicon Valley a big venture capitalists
called Sequoia Capital had sent out a
deck said our IP good times get to
cashflow positive and there was just no
money anywhere so for us what we did so
a it's obviously super I have a
co-founding team of four total and good
news is we got along which was great and
we were pretty cheap so we got even
cheaper we cut our we cut our burn
drastically
and we basically hunker down all of us
in some ways because we were smaller it
felt really good that we were all in the
same boat together for about two to
three years our Christmas party was
basically an office party with board
games but I'm gonna really complain too
much so that's pretty good with a gift
exchange which is great and I think the
other thing that we did that was for us
and I'm not saying it's for everybody
but we did change our business model
during that time because we saw
basically three million dollar contracts
just disappear overnight and we said we
just cannot kind of function with that
and we were just stupid enough to just
try to continue to exist during that
time until funding came in about a year
later and that's when we just walked
down to the pub and had a drink after
the money goes in the bank so by the way
term sheets are sign that means nothing
you got to wait till money's in the bank
choice so the first three years of that
we were around we actually only were
able to raise a hundred and get a
hundred thousand dollars and so for the
Bay Area that's not a lot of money so I
mean the number one rule in a start-up
before especially if you don't product
market fit yet is just to keep your
personal burn low so you got a you know
you yeah you can't spend money on
anything only on the the must needs so I
mean we couldn't afford board games I
guess you could there's the library
check out you could check them up but
honestly it's just keeping your personal
burn low and just having a good
relationship with your co-founder and
just being on the same page of where
you're going and keep trying and just
like you guys pivoted we actually it's
funny because we pivoted also into the
thing that started growing then got us a
venture capital during this time when we
were just like on credit cards and and
barely making it so we pivoted into
games yeah like that mentality it's like
that that mentality of not you don't
have anything really makes you think it
makes your be really efficient with what
you do and it really makes you think
what you can do with very little and I
think that's actually when some of the
better ideas come about so even if you
raise money you should always keep that
in mind and keep that mentality and
mindset and always keep your burnt low
yeah okay so another interesting
question especially for this conference
are there differences that you've seen
in interviews between male founders and
female founders in terms of how they
present etc Christy do want to start so
I guess of of the women that have come
in and the women that we have taste so I
don't know in terms of pitching but I do
realize there's one thing that I
realized not just from this one but over
time is partly for I've heard this
advice given to men about in order to
sound very smart is to speak slower but
I feel like that advice doesn't help for
women I actually think the ones that
just bowled us over with the numbers of
like this is this this this and this and
we're like wow okay and those were the
ones that we ended up taking it was like
okay that that like they just didn't
even give in edgewise in some ways it's
not like they weren't listening either
you definitely have to be open to
listening but I'd have to think a little
bit was there a difference in terms or
maybe eg as founders who have pitched
investors were there things that you
kind of had to coach yourself on that
you had to improve upon yeah definitely
I know some of the stuff sounds really
silly but doing those Superman poses
like getting your head in the game the
visualization pieces practice practice
practice practice practice practice and
know your numbers but I'll let you talk
about them honestly I think it's like
knowing your numbers I don't know that's
just the number one thing and I always
just knew my numbers and was able to if
you ask me anything I would I could tell
you in a split second and I think I
think that's super important I think
confidence just going in and even if
it's like I said before even if it's
super awkward feeling just just being
confident there in the beginning it was
really fun
because when I was asking for money I'd
always like smile weirdly we're like
like almost crack up because it was just
so awkward for me so I just had to get
out of that phase and just because
there's always a silence also after you
ask and you should just pause don't
start like some people just start
rambling after that because the other
person hasn't spoken yet but it's you
know just pause and wait for the
reaction so I was I was I've been
talking to a lot of the international
founders and one French founder actually
a man a male French founder you know
came up to me and said you know demo day
is coming up and I have to say I'm
really uncomfortable because you know
American men pitch themselves in such
this like overblown bold way and we're
not taught like to speak like that in
France I mean it's very embarrassing and
uncomfortable and so it's just something
that we had to practice if that he you
know could fight past that discomfort
because you have to you know a lot of
investors are sort of used to seeing
these you know kind of bold confident
pitches and so that is something that I
think you know you know international
founders but also I see some women like
kind of undersell themselves I was
reading hackathon applications a couple
years ago it was the first time I
noticed it would be teams mixed teams
male female and you know the male on the
team would say hey we built this
world-changing award-winning hack at
this last and you know hackathon were an
incredible team we're the best on the
planet stuff like that and his female
counterpart who had built that same you
know hack with him said you know I
contributed to this product and it was
really like a stark contrast and it's
something that I saw over and over again
and so it just made me whenever I talk
to women I'm like don't undersell you
know what you're doing or what you're
bringing to this team because you're an
important piece of it and so that's I
think a main thing that I tell women
over and over again before they go out
and pitch and don't apologize I'm
practicing that
I'm sorry I have one more question I
have a couple more questions but I just
wanted to do that um so what would be
the advice so we we are at YC I've
obviously seen a lot of companies go
from that early stage to the growth
stage so what do you think some of the
best advice is for that for a company as
they're getting to that next phase and
maybe they're like getting over 30
employees approaching 50 employees so
there's there's two sides to it there's
one the product side in terms of how do
you grow your product and the most
important thing is knowing your unit
economics like at the one unit level how
much does how much money are you making
on each piece or each person that comes
in because then you could dump a bunch
of money in there and be and it's gonna
be smart how it's going to be spent so
on your product side you should
definitely know how your unit economics
are and they should be positive just in
case anybody does not know it should be
positive and I know it might be a little
different for advertising based company
and even b2b it looks at a are our
average annual recurring revenue and all
that but for the most part if you get
your unit economics right then that that
is something that's that's important as
you grow there's something that changes
also from product market fit the
organization changes and I think people
don't talk about that as much but that
is incredibly important to be able to
enable your product to grow and from
that stage it's almost like I'm pretty
sure that the CEO gets hurt hit first in
terms of feeling that kind of like okay
it's time to scale like I don't even
know where the keys to the building are
like how do I even get in there and then
it starts hitting the next layer perhaps
like for us it was a other co-founders
such as myself I'm like I don't even
know where the files are the design
files because I hired another designer
and at that point you start thinking
about well about managing all of this
stuff you're like oh my god this is big
corporate stuff I'm here to get [ __ ]
done right and what people don't realize
is when you get [ __ ] done sometimes you
just end up with a lot of [ __ ] oh my
gosh this is being recorded huh I'm
sorry livestreams stops done
and stuff so sorry for everybody out
there
oh no apologists ain't sorry I'm not
supposed anyways the problem with that
mindset especially as you're growing is
you end up with just a lot of crap and
you have people doing the same thing in
like three or four different places and
you're just like what is going on and so
you have to start moving into a mindset
of making it happen like looking at it
as a whole organized this organ
organism particularly those that are
leading the company and then you as
founders which i think is incredibly a
difficult special and probably
irrational place to be is that it's it's
you have to learn how to scale yourself
and that's something that take a lot of
confidence and pride and that your
founder and we all know that you're
learning on the job and every day you're
failing every single day the learning
curve is like like 50 percent is a
phenomenal score because it's on a on a
curve so that those are things that you
have to kind of learn in terms of like
how do you start managing through people
how do you start knowing delegation and
how you yourself like how do you you
yourself recharge and be able to work
with other folks so but there's a lot of
other pieces on setting up an
organization but that's something that
you start thinking about you know you're
building an organization and then a
company
alright so primary person just one thing
that what we see startups that don't
work out what one of the things that
they always do is that they run out of
money because what they've done is while
they're growing they've just thrown
humans at problems like the human
band-aid solution is it's not thing you
should do meaning you know you just hire
as many engineers as you can because you
know you have all these features you
want to build and your product roadmaps
behind or you know you don't have enough
lead so you go hire more marketing
people you should not do that and just
think of other ways be more to be more
efficient and get back like I said to
that startup mindset of being super
efficient awesome um another question
and maybe Kirsty you could take this one
how do you how does YC you feel about
companies that have already raised the
money so they're applying and they maybe
have is there is there an amount that's
too much for them to have in their cap
table before they apply to waste
so we we have companies apply and
companies that we accept who have raised
have millions of dollars in the past
it's a real spectrum and another
misconception is people will will say
I'm too early for YC or I'm too late for
YC and actually neither of those things
are true so you will apply and we'll do
our job and figure out whether whether
you know you're the right fit and so you
know we do have companies that have come
to us having already raised money on
safes some companies have already raised
seed rounds you know and and we think
that the the three-month batch in
particular you know we can be really
helpful to any companies who are sort of
up to series a and sometimes even having
raised a Series A so you know I think
it's it's less about the dollars that
you've raised and more about where are
you in the process and and you know how
how can you leverage YC in the three
months that you get as part of the
program to actually make the company as
much of a success as it possibly can and
I just the last question we have a lot
of versions of kind of the flip side of
that question so we've talked a little
bit about like how someone can show
progress early but um what are in terms
of early stage companies what are some
of like how early can you possibly get
into YC and I think maybe would help to
just give some examples of founders
who've gotten in a little bit on the
earlier side and what the reasons might
have been so so we definitely have
companies who are super early you know
we'll often have people who come in and
we agree to fund who haven't even
incorporated yet so they're that early
you know and it it depends on on what
was the idea and what's going on in
terms of the company but also bear in
mind that even companies or founders can
come in with an idea that they've been
working on for six months or for a year
and during the three months of the batch
they decide to pivot into something
entirely different so they're starting
from absolute zero as well so you know
it doesn't always just have to be at the
point of the application
and any any early usage or any early
indicators of people really loving what
it is that you're building is is often
enough for us to be able to to take that
bet on you I'll just plug that YC has a
program called startup school startup
school org and it'll be another program
later this year which is literally
anyone who has an idea I can participate
in that and and watch that content
I think that's is it I guess I'll have
the last word thank you so much to the
YC partners and thank you to everyone
okay I have a couple thank you so I
wanted to thank you all for coming today
and I hope you'll you know stay in touch
with us and let us know what you're
working on and stay in touch with each
other so a couple things I want to thank
you to Google for hosting the kickoff
dinner last night and to Silicon Valley
Bank for hosting the brunch this morning
I'm one piece of feedback we always get
from folks that attend is that they
don't have enough time to sort of meet
the other attendees so thank you for
doing that I also wanted to let you know
that AWS Amazon Web Services and Google
cloud are both offering hosting credits
to everyone here so keep an eye out for
an email for me I'll email you all sort
of instructions on how to take
advantages of those if you need or want
them and then I also wanted to thank the
riveter for hosting us because this is
an incredible space and I wanted to
thank Abney from poppy because she's one
of the major reasons we're here she was
such a big advocate
she's like constantly telling us how
many talented women there are in Seattle
so thank you
and one last thing is I wanted to well
two last things one is and we have
phenomenal women t-shirts for everyone
here so make sure to pick one up on your
way out and they are a non-profit you
can check them out there they're an
incredible organization and so remember
to get those before you head to the
reception at Red Hook brew lab down the
street and then also my last last thing
is I wanted to thank everyone at YC ya
who made this happen there's like ten of
us who came out especially Dom Dominic
finds who heads up events for YC so you
did an incredible job and thank you
[Applause]
Red Hook brew lab we will see you there
any anything else you use your badges
was that
[Applause]